in this course you will learn how to
automate a bunch of different things in
python you will learn about web scraping
automating downloads extracting from
pdfs automated image processing building
an automated news summarizer and more
the instructor for this course is abdul
also known as one little coder he has
been creating courses for a while and is
a great teacher
welcome to the section one of hands-on
built tools to automate stuff in python
in this section we'll build a hacker
news headlines emailer we'll begin with
the understanding of the basics of web
scraping then we'll set up our system
environment by installing the required
python packages then we'll move on to
understand the project architecture and
then we'll start scraping project with
hacker news front page and then finally
we'll complete the email section to
finish the tool building so that the
tool can send us the hacker news
headlines
in this video we'll learn about project
architecture of building an automated
hacker news headlines emailer
this architecture starts with getting
the content of the hacker news website
front page so we'll use the python
package request to get the get request
to extract the content of the website
once we have the content of the website
in place we'll use the python package
beautiful soup to scrape the required
content so the required content i mean
the components like title
link score domain name etc so we'll use
beautiful soup to extract these required
components from the content that we had
extracted from the previous step
the next step is to build the email body
or the content of the email
from the scraped content
will arrange it in such a way that the
email body looks like there is a title
there is a link there is a number so
that the email body looks exactly like a
news presentation and once we have the
email body ready we'll move on to the
email authentication section where we
will use our gmail id to authenticate
the email section
we'll use the python package
smtp lib to set up an smtp library
authentication system
where we'll use our gmail authentication
once the authentication is set up and
then we have provided our email id and
then other necessary information finally
we are going to send that email using
the email body that we have set up so
ultimately what we are doing is we are
extracting content from the web page and
then we are going to take the required
components and then use that component
to build an email body and then use that
email body
in an email that we composed and then we
sent it to the required users
in the next video we'll start to learn
how to set up our python environment in
such a way that we have all the required
packages
in this video we'll learn how to set up
our python environment in such a way
that we have all the required packages
these are the following packages that we
will be using in this particular project
request package is used for http request
beautiful soup is used for web scraping
smtp lib is used for email
authentication and email transaction
email.mime is used
for creating that email body and then
finally date time is used for accessing
or manipulating date and time
but in these packages smtp lib
email.mime and daytime comes by default
with your python installation so what we
have to do is there are two external
libraries request package and beautiful
soup that we are supposed to install in
our python environment so let us go
ahead and see how to install those two
packages that are required
first open your terminal and then make
sure that you have python installed
already once you have python installed
already you can start with pip3
install requests once you enter it
python is going to look up for request
and then it is going to get request
package from pipe i which is the
repository where all the packages are
available and then it is going to
install in your machine to check if
request package is installed let us
invoke our python 3 console and then
check import
request
as you can see it has successfully
imported so let us exit and now move
ahead with the next package
the next package that we are supposed to
install is
pip 3 install
beautiful soup
oh
so now again beautiful soup is getting
downloaded from pie pie and then
beautiful soup is getting installed so
as we can see beautiful soup is
installed now let us go ahead and invoke
our python 3 console and then check if
beautiful soup is installed
as you can see beautiful soup even
though is the package name while you are
importing the package in your python
section you have to use bs4 as you can
see bs4 is successfully installed you
can even check if a particular object is
getting imported bs from bs4 import
beautiful so as you can see b is capital
here and s also also capital so it is
successfully imported so
let us exit our python environment so
now we have successfully installed
beautiful soup for and then request
package both are the external libraries
that are required for this particular
project and all other packages like smtp
email.mime and datetime are inbuilt
present in our python setup
but let us make sure that those packages
are available also so let us invoke our
python console once again python 3.
let us clear our terminal first
open python 3
and then do import smtp
smtp is successfully imported and let us
import email dot my
email.mime is successfully imported let
us import date time daytime is also
successfully imported so this tells us
that all the required packages are
available in the python environment that
we have got so we are good to go ahead
with our project
in this video we'll start to learn how
to code the project script
for this code editing i'm using pycharm
community edition
but you can use any ide of your choice
so make sure that python installation is
proper in your machine and python is
added in the system path then you can
use any code editor to do the same thing
that i'm going to show you right now
we'll start with importing all the
packages that are required and if you
remember those are the packages that we
installed
in the previous section
and we'll start with import request
which is for our http request and then
we'll import beautiful soup from bs4
next
we'll move on to importing smtp lib
and then
we'll import two objects
from email mime and then finally we'll
import date time
once all the inputs are finished we'll
start with extracting the current date
time
which is the system date time
the reason we are using date time to
extract the current
date time is
to create an email subject line where it
will show us the appropriate date when
the email was sent this is for us to
make sure that the same email get
doesn't get overwritten every day so
that we have an understanding that every
day we are receiving a new email from
the automated emailer so the next step
is to create an empty python object with
nothing it's a string object with
nothing in it
which is going to be used as an email
content placeholder
once we are ready with this thing we can
move on to start creating a new function
where we will extract the hacker news
components that we are required
first let us create a function
called extract underscore news which
will take one argument which is the url
that it is required so to keep the user
updated will print a user message saying
extracting hacker news stories then
we'll create another temporary
placeholder which is again an msd string
so this temporary placeholder is going
to be used to
assign value to this content which is
the actual email body that we want so
the first line that we want in our email
body is to say that this is hn top
stories hn stands for hacker news and
then we are going to display hn top
stories
and
it is going to be a bold text and then
we are going to have line breaks and
then we are going to show star star star
star just to make it more readable
once this line is defined now we will
move on to get the content of the url
the url that we are going to pass to
this function when we call this function
so we are going to use request packets
get function to get the content of this
url and then store it in the response
object
the content once we get from the get
function is actually a response body
http response
which will contain content the actual
content that is required for us which is
the content of the webpage so we are
going to use the method content
on the object response to store the
actual content in content remember this
is a global object
which is content and this is a local
object within this particular function
which means these two are different so
the scope of this particular content
lies only within this function so do not
get confused with this content and this
content
now we are going to use this content
that we extracted using the response
body
and we are going to use a html parser to
extract or make a soup out of it
from that particular soup what we are
going to be interested is about the
components that we are going to require
in this
particular project so to understand what
are the components that we are going to
required we have to see the website
structure so in the next video we will
see the website structure of the hacker
news front page to see what are the
components that we would be required to
extract using this beautiful soup
function
in this video we'll see what are the
components that we need from the hacker
news front page website and as you can
see from this code this is the url that
we are going to use and this is the
hacker news front page url so let us go
to our browser so in this case i'm using
mozilla firefox so let us go to our
browser and then open hacker news front
page and this is how the site actually
looks this is one of the most popular
websites on the internet and this was
started by paul graham was a very famous
personality
and internet entrepreneur and he also
runs an incubator called y combinator so
this is a website that has been read by
thousands and thousands of people every
day and our objective is to extract this
content and automatically send an email
to us so that we can see
only when there is an important or
interesting content for us to see then
we can go to the website
and that is the objective of this entire
project so as we can see
this website we can see a header in this
website or a navigation bar and then we
have list
which is uh very similar to how you know
rated kind of website look so in this
setup there are some components that we
could be interested in to understand
what is the link or what is the
information is about first we need this
one which is the actual title of the
link then we would be also interested in
knowing the points which shows how
popular that particular link is so to
know what are the contents that we
should be scraping from this website we
have to first open our web inspector
to open web inspector you can either
press f12 in your keyboard or you can
right click in your machine the browser
using your mouse and then click inspect
element so click inspect element then
you will get this particular page opened
which will give you
a sense of how the web page is designed
so let us slightly increase the size of
this
and let us pick
the
pick and element tool so now we have
picked up this tool to understand what
are the components that we need from
this particular hacker news front page
which we will use
in the code to extract that particular
component from the content that we have
already extracted so pick this thing and
then go here as you can see this as you
hover you can actually see the css value
which is also called the selector as you
can see
over you can see a dot story link here
you can see a dot hn user
a dot some score value then you can
actually see a then you can see a so
what we can see is
we can click mouse and then see how
we don't have to actually click we can
just hover around and we can actually
see how the code changes and then the
first area of interest for us is the
title so hover your mouse there and
click the button
as you can see
once you hover there what you actually
get is you get an
a anchor text with the class story link
and which is present inside
a table with class title so the first
point that we are looking for is
anchor text with story link so let us go
to our code and see
what we have written so what is our area
of interest is we are trying to extract
everywhere where we have got tb
td is in html
is the actual cell
inside a table html table html table is
created using this tag table
a table row is created using this tag tr
and then the values the actual cells
inside the table row is using created
using the tag
t d so in this step what we are trying
to do is we are trying to tell
beautiful sue
to find
all td from this particular soup
so we have just created the soup so we
are using the function find all to find
everything that is td but as you can see
we are trying to find
everywhere where there is td with class
title so as you can see we are trying to
find everywhere where there is class
title
and then we are trying to extract the
components of it
everywhere there is class title then we
are trying to extract the components
or the values inside it
that is exactly what we're doing in this
function soup dot find all
td and then the attributes the html
attributes that we are looking for is
class title
and then we align we align is something
that you can actually see
so this is what we are trying to find
out from this particular webpage so we
are trying to find
everything that is td
and we are trying to extract that using
this attribute class title and then we
are saying we align should be empty so
the first attribute class should have
value title the second attribute we
align should have nothing in it so just
let us see it once again once you click
the inspector tool and then hover on the
web page you click on the title that you
want and you can actually see the title
the td class attribute holds the value
title and then the we align like this
one is not present here so this is to
eliminate the junk and then extract the
component that we want
so once we do that
we are trying to find wherever we are
trying to convert the entire thing as a
text so to see that we have to
understand one more thing what we are
actually seeing is
this is okay so we are extracting td
which has class title but that is only
for the
first element but what we need is we
need all the links we need all the 30
links from this particular page
for us to do that we are trying to put
this entire thing in a for loop and then
we are using this function enumerate
just for one simple purpose because in
the final email that we want we want
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 6 until 30.
so for that purpose we are trying to
use enumerate which will give us the
actual number the index value and also
the value of this output so we are using
a for loop and we are using enumerate to
say okay i want all the values
that this output of this thing which
will give us all the text all the
scraped output and then we are saying
enumerated so that we have the index
value and we also have the actual tag
that is extracted from this page
and once we do that we are entering into
the for loop trying to build the email
content actual content so as we just
discussed
we are trying to create the table row
number with this value i and as you can
see
python is a zero index language so what
we are trying to do is we are trying to
say okay i plus 1 which will give us 1
for the first row and then 2 3 until 30
so on and then we are going to we are
trying to actually have a nice looking
format just like this which will
separate the
index number from the actual title and
then we are trying to convert everything
what we are trying to do is we are
trying to convert everything that we
just extracted using dot text into a
text so we are trying to say okay you
have given me the tag but i don't want
the entire tag i just want the text
inside the tag so the value inside the
tag so we are using tag dot text to do
that
and then now we need a line break so we
are going to use br which is an html tag
for the line break and then one more
thing is required here which is
if you can notice in this particular
page you have got all the title let us
again open our web inspector and you
have got all the title but at the end of
the page you actually have another title
which is td class title we align nothing
but this value is more so in order to
avoid this more getting captured in our
final output email body we are trying to
eliminate this saying that we want
everything 1 to 30
except when there is a value more
that is what exactly we are doing we are
saying we want everything
except when the tag is not equal to more
we are saying give me everything when
the tag is not equal to more and then we
are concatenating it for every row so
this for loop is executing for every row
and then every row value is getting
added in the cnt and at the end of this
function we are returning this object
python object that we created which was
an empty placeholder string as c and t
to recap this particular function this
function is to extract
the front page
links or title or the components that we
wanted so we are creating a function
called extract underscore news where we
are passing on the url and then we are
creating a nice title which says hn top
stories and then we are extracting the
content we are using beautiful soup to
extract make a soup out of it and then
we are using soup dot find all to find
all the td tags with attributes class
title and then we align nothing and then
we are trying to create rows using this
thing and while we are creating rows we
also noticed that there is one final row
which has a value more which we do not
want so we are excluding that and then
finally we are retaining the entire
object
cnt as the result of this function
in the next section we will see how to
call the function and then we'll move on
to composing the email
in the previous video we learned how to
build the custom function that we use
for extracting the news from hacker news
friend page
in this video we'll see how to call that
function how to finish the email content
and then how to start with email
authentication so to start with we can
see the function that we try to build in
the previous section is called extract
underscore news that takes one argument
which is url
so to invoke the function or to call the
function we are going to say extract
underscore news and then we are going to
pass on the url of that hacker news
friend page as a string once we do this
thing
this function gets executed and then
whatever is written in cnt will get
assigned to this particular cnt and as
we saw in the previous section
this cnt is a local object whose scope
is within this function and this cnt is
part of a global object which has scope
in the entire code
once we have this cnt what we are going
to do is we are going to append this cnt
to the content placeholder that we
created so we are saying just content
plus equal to which is as equivalent as
content is equal to content plus
so instead of this thing we are going to
simply say content
cnt
plus equal to cnt at the end of the
email body then we are trying to put
empty lines with dashes to denote that
the email is finished and then finally
we are going to add two more lines and
then say this is the end of the message
this is just for us to make the email
more professional more useful in
understanding where the email starts
with this thing and where the email
actually ends
once we have this finished what we are
going to now do is we are going to start
with the email composing step and then
the first step of email composing is to
create the parameters that is required
for email authentication
as we saw in the project um architecture
section so once the email composition
the email body is ready we are going to
start with the email authentication for
email authentication there are five
important parameters that we have to
define first
what is the email server the smtp the
server that you are going to use second
what is the port number
third what is the from address email
address where you want to send the email
what is the to address
where you want to send the email and
then finally the password of the address
from address from where you want to send
that email
one thing that you have to keep in mind
is this to address could be actually a
list where you want to send this email
to multiple recipients so in this
particular project we will see how to
send this email to yourself so that you
can keep yourself updated with hacker
news headlines every day
but
actually you can even send this email to
multiple person provided that you give a
list of email ids list when i mean list
it's actually a python list so to start
with we are going to use a gmail account
for this particular step so we are going
to stay
smtp.gmail.com which is the smtp email
server for gmail and for gmail the port
number is 587 and then the next thing is
the from email id which should be in a
character as a string so
for the sake of this particular project
i'm going to use my gmail account from
where i want to send my email and then
also this is the same email id for which
i want to send this email to
remember the two address could be a list
of email ids where we have multiple
email address so that this one email
could be sent to a lot of people and
then finally we have the password
that we are going to use
for this email account so you enter the
password
that is required to log into this
account and then this will complete the
parameters that we wanted
once we have this in place the next
thing is we are going to create the
message body so the message body that we
want is a mime multipart so we are
creating an empty
object with using the function my
multipart and then we have to add the
subsequent components of an email an
email is supposed to have an important
thing which is called an email subject
so to create an email subject there are
multiple things that we can actually do
the first naivety thing that we can
actually do is we can have a title that
doesn't change but the disadvantage with
that is in an email client like gmail or
outlook if you have the same title every
email that comes next day gets folded in
the same conversation
instead of having a different email the
same email will be there and then
subsequent emails will be added as a
conversation so to avoid that and also
for us to understand when did we receive
that particular email
what we are going to do is we are going
to create a dynamic email subject and
the way we are going to do that is as
you can remember from the previous
videos
we had created a new object python
object that called now
from the date time package which will
return the system date the current date
so what we are doing here is we are
saying okay this is my email subject
which says top news stories
an automated email that's well and good
next what we are trying to do is we are
trying to actually create the date
object str now dot day will give you the
day
the next one is str now dot month the
next one is str now here so what we are
trying to do is we are actually trying
to create an email subject line that has
the date component date
day and then your year
so once we have this thing we are going
to assign it in this my multipart that
we created as subject the next is the
from address from the next two address
s2 and once we are done with this thing
we are going to attach the email body
the email body that we created as
message msg.attach as you can notice
here we are trying to make this an html
email
so if you remember we had used be bold
as html tags to make our email look
slightly more better than a normal text
email
and that is why we are using mime text
should be content html and then we are
attaching that content to the email so
with this our email body is currently
ready now we are moving on to the
authentication section where we are
printing the message that initializing
server
once we have the server components in
place the next step that we are going to
do is we are going to
call smtp function from the smtp lib
package and then we are saying okay this
is my server this is my port i'm going
to assign it to server and then this
function set underscore debug level one
is to say whether we want to see debug
messages if the server has issue in
connecting if the server has any problem
if the authentication is not successful
do you want to see the error messages or
no so if you do not want to see the
error messages you can set zero if you
want to see the error messages you can
set one
which will help you in debugging once we
have that thing we are going to initiate
the server with a hello and then we are
going to start
a tls connection which is a secured
connection and then once that is done we
are going to log in from
id using the password that we have given
once the login is successful then
finally we are going to send the email
that we have composed from this id to
this id where the message that we have
created is sent as a string using the
function as underscore string once the
message is sent successfully we are
going to print a user message email send
and then finally we are going to quit
from the server that we just initialized
so we are going to initialize the server
using the server and port detail that we
just created
we are going to set the debug level one
to understand the error messages we are
going to initiate the transaction with
the server
starting with alo and then starting with
a tls server and then we are going to
login to the from and
the id email id and then using the
password and then finally we are going
to send the email from this id to this
id or set of ids that we have created
here
and then finally we are going to send it
as a message using this as underscore
string function and then finally we are
printing a user message and then we are
going to quit from the server
in the next video we'll see how the
email actually looks and then how do we
execute the script
in the previous section we completed the
actual code that was required for this
particular project
but before we move on to executing the
code there is one change that you have
to do if you are going to use your gmail
account if you are going to use your
custom smtp like your company email id
or you are going to have your own email
server you probably would not need to
know this thing but if you are going to
use your gmail account to send an
automated email this is one mandatory
step that you have to do otherwise your
email would throw authentication error
so what is that thing
so what you have to do is you have to go
to your email account so what you have
to do is you have to go to
myaccount.google.com
security so this is what you have to
open you have to go to
myaccount.google.com
security and then you go to security tab
once you get into the security tab you
will see something called list secure
app access so you'll see list secure app
access once you scroll down the top page
looks like this so once you go at the
end you will see list secure app access
so click this button
right now i have it
on but for you it should be ideally off
so what you have to do is you have to
turn it on so read this message
carefully once google is trying to tell
you that you are trying to enable
your email sign in for less secure
technology
and this project that we are doing it is
calling it as less secure technology
because it doesn't use two-factor
authentication unlike your mobile phone
or mobile app or something else
so google is trying to
let you know that you are trying to
access
or give access to your gmail login for
less secure app and this is how exactly
the message is for all the email
automation project that you would do so
that is completely fine but make sure if
you have two factor authentication this
is not going to work probably you have
to find another way which you can find
in google forums but for
normal login if you have a normal login
this is what you have to do you have to
go to
myaccount.google.com security you go
click this button and then by default it
would be like this for you which is off
and then you have to go here and then
turn it on
once you turn it on you'll see this
message
and then you will have an yellow color
let me refresh the page
it would take slightly some time
for google to refresh your on to off and
after on
so probably you have to wait executing
this until that so now you can actually
see that this is refreshed and then it
is showing with an exclamatory mark
which is
slightly a warning sign to say that you
have enabled
your gmail login
for less secure apps once you're done
with this step now you can go ahead and
then execute
your code
and then let us open go to the python
community edition that we were using let
us open the terminal
so please note you can even go to your
system terminal and then do this thing
or even you can use your pycharm
terminal for the first time we'll use
your pycharm terminal to see what are
the error messages that we are getting
if you are getting some error messages
or if you are not going to get any error
messages
then we can probably you know automate
this entire thing using windows patch
scheduler or a bash script
that would be just simply run on your
terminal or shell so to start with what
we have to do is we let us see what are
all the files that we have these are the
files that we have in this thing and
this is the particular file that we are
of interest we will say python3 and then
we are testing the file name and then
executing it as you can see these are
the error messages or user messages that
we were printing and now because we had
enabled debug level one this message has
been sent
and
you can see that it is showing that this
is
first extracting hacker new stories
composing email initiating server all
the ip address related details now
starting the tls server and then it is
saying that ok smtp has started and then
from this email you are sending it to
this email
and then this is your email body
starting with
automated email and then finally you're
finishing the email and then you are
presenting a message that email sent and
then the email connection is closed
we'll see how to do the same thing using
your terminal so open the terminal that
you have start with the terminal that
you have like in my case i'm going to
open my mac terminal and then i'm going
to first navigate to the place where i
have got the codes
once you navigate to the folder where
you have got the codes
now check what are all the files you
have got so these are the files that we
have got so copy the file name
now open python 3
and then file name
now you are executing first extracting
the news composing the email and it is
the same set of messages
that we have seen
so in this video we learned
how to enable the google setting that
will allow us to send automated email
through our gmail and then we also saw
how to execute our script both in the
pycharm and also in our terminal
so the way we execute this
using this code python 3 which is to
execute python 3 or invoke python 3
console and then the file name
in the next video we'll actually see how
the email looks like
in this video
we'll see how the email that we sent
using the previous automated script
actually looks like
let us go to our gmail
as you can see google has sent me a
critical security alert which is just to
notify that i had tried to
enable my account login for less secure
apps and you know that is completely
fine for us to
see and then ignore and then the next
thing is we can see the email that we
sent as you can see you have received
two emails because the first email was
sent using the terminal inside pycharm
the second email was sent using the
shell the actual terminal that is in
your os which is your command prompt
terminal
so let us open the email let us slightly
zoom out to see how the email actually
looks like as you can see this is the
subject of the email where this is
static what we created and then this is
the date that is the current system date
and then you can see a bold email title
not the subject actually email title and
you can also see that email was sent
from to this email
and you can actually see another
important thing that this email has
fallen inside your inbox and not inside
your spam box so what happens is if you
do not have all the email components the
mime components that we set up your
email might end up in your spam not in
your inbox so make sure that you have
got all the email components that we
described in the code setup right
so now you can see that you have a title
then you have all the formatting that we
did then you have the number that we
used
using the enumerate index i and then we
have this formatting the separator and
then we have the title and then finally
we have the domain name with the link in
fact as you can see we have 30 and then
finally we have this thing and then we
finally say end of message so let us
open the next email also to see okay the
first one is this the second one is this
and then we have all the 30 items and
then finally we are saying it is end of
message let us once go to the hacker
news site and then verify what is it
as you can see bullshitters is the first
bullshitters is the first
how to set up setting up an ad block
setting up an ad block
there's no thought probably it has
changed by the time we send that email
and how to hide from a surveillance how
to hide from a surveillance so this
makes sure that
the email that we sent is the actual
hacker news for this time 25 for 2019 at
this time 25 for 2019
so
in this video we saw how the actual
email that we sent using the previous
script looks like and in this section
we have learnt how to build
an automated hacker news headline
emailer which now further you can extend
to
probably a windows cache scheduler to
send it every day morning or using a
bash script scheduler or a cron job
to automatically send this email even
without executing so in the
video start of the video the previous
section end we learned how to execute
the script but once you automate it
using a task scheduler or a bash script
or a cron job then probably you would
not have to even open or run the script
every day the script would be
automatically executed there is only one
important thing that you have to keep in
your mind before you know we close this
section is that
this email script will contain your
email password
so make sure before you upload it on
github or before you share it with your
friends the same script that you remove
your password so that no one else knows
your password so in this entire project
what we learned is how to scrape a
website how to extract the components
that we want how to build an email and
how to automatically send that email
from our gmail account hope you enjoyed
this section let us see in the next
section
in this section two we'll learn how to
build a ted talk video downloader we'll
see how to install requests package and
understand how to use request package
for http requests with that we'll build
the basic script to download the video
of a given ted talk and then will store
the video in our local machine then
we'll generalize the code to download
any ted talk video given the url and
will ultimately package the script as a
cli tool
in this video we'll see all the packages
that we'll be using in this project
the first and foremost package that we
are going to use in this project is
requests
request
is the package that will help us get the
web content and the request the name
comes from
http request which is how the
communication between a server and
client happens in a http protocol the
client sends request to the server and
then the server responds back
sends the response as a result a typical
http request contains the actual request
and then the header lines
like authentication and then an optional
empty message body so sometimes you can
have
the information that is required to be
passed on in that message body the
package that we are going to use for
that is request in python so let us see
how to install that required package
inside our computer so open your
terminal and then as you might have seen
before because we are using python 3 we
should use pip3
install
request
this will install request package from
pi pi so now as you can see request
package is successfully installed to
verify that we can open our python 3
console and then import request
and then see that it has been
successfully installed thank you for
listening we'll see the next video
about another package which is beautiful
soup
in this video we'll see about beautiful
soup beautiful soup is another important
package that we'll be using in this
project beautiful soup is used to
extract data out of html and xml
primarily beautiful soup is used for
whip scraping so the request package
that we saw in the last video will give
us a content from the webpage but as you
might have guessed the content is an
html or xml format in which websites are
designed so beautiful soup is the
package that will give us the formatted
content the extract of whatever we want
from the html or xml file that we
requested from the request package as a
get request let us see how to install
beautiful soup package inside our python
environment
beautiful soup goes by the name
beautiful soup 4. so open your terminal
type pip3
install and beautiful soup for
everything in small case once you click
enter beautiful soup will be collected
from pie pie and then it is going to get
successfully installed in your local
machine to verify whether beautiful
supers install let us open up our python
environment which is python 3 and then
import
bs4
as you might have seen the package that
we installed was beautiful soup but when
we are going to call it we are going to
use beautiful bs4 as beautiful soup
and especially the function that we are
going to use the object that we are
going to use from beautiful surface
from bs4 import beautiful
this is the object that we are going to
use from the package beautiful soup so
as you can see when you install it you
have to call it beautiful soup four when
you import it you have to call bs4 and
then from that this is a specific object
that we are going to use inside our code
let us get into the next video where
we'll see how to build the basic code
thank you
in this video we'll see how to build the
first version of the ted talk video
downloader as we have seen in the
previous videos we have successfully
installed request package and we have
successfully also installed beautiful
suit package so let us start with the
code
let us import the required packages
first in the header section and then let
us move on to the code the first package
that we are going to use is request so
let us import request and the second
package is beautiful so as we saw in the
beautiful soup package video
we are going to import beautiful soup
the object from the package bs4
and once we do that the next package
that we would be requiring is r e which
is for regular expression manipulation
so regular expression as you might have
known is just to do pattern matching and
then finally the package that we are
going to use is sys which is for
argument parsing which is to generalize
the code for using multiple urls as a
combined package so let us start with
the code so as we have imported the
required packages in our header section
we'll move on to the further section
we'll see this exception handling in the
next video meanwhile we'll use a url
that is hard coded so here there is a
url of a ted talk and that is defined in
the object url so the first step is to
use request package to send a get
request to get the content of the url
and store in the object r
so because this is going to be a long
process it is also good to enter message
to the user who is using this package
the project that we have developing
to indicate that the download is about
to start
once the request packages successfully
get all the content from the url of this
ted talk the next thing that we are
going to do is we are going to use
beautiful soup to create a soup out of
the content that we have got
as you can see here the
response of the get
request is stored in r which is the
poisson object but here when we are
going to use it with beautiful so we are
going to say r dot content it is because
the response contains a lot of things
like the status code
the result of the request so in this
entire response body the only thing that
we are interested is
are that content which is the actual
content of the website url that we
extracted and once we are going to use
beautiful soup to assign it to the soup
object the next step is to identify the
exact location where we have got the mp4
to understand that let us actually see
the source code of the
a talk page
when you open a title just like this
when you press ctrl u you will get the
actual source of the project
the page in this page we have to see
where np4 is present so we'll say
control f mp4
as you can see this is the place where
you have mp4 and we are interested to
extract this particular url but before
that we have to see where the exact
location this mp4 is present in this
entire page so we'll just scroll to the
first
and we'll see that this entire content
is present inside a script that starts
with talk page in it and that's exactly
what we are going to use our beautiful
soup code to find within this entire
page so entire content is present in
soup and then we are going to say inside
soup find everywhere where you have
script and inside that script using
rejects regular expression we are going
to find for this particular word and
then we are going to store the result
inside result and as you can see from
this
entire script this script contains a lot
of text and the only part that we are
interested in is a proper mp4 file so we
are building a regular expression
pattern to say that it should start with
the url should start with https and then
it will contain also mp4 and then we are
going to assign the result in result
underscore mp4
at this point you might have got a lot
of results so what we are going to do is
we are going to split everything based
on one separator and then we are going
to take the first
output after the split as the proper mp4
url because as you can see with the mp4
you actually see medium quality light
quality high quality so
not bothering about the quality of the
videos we are going to just take the
first
url
after the split and then finally we are
going to print a message that we are
going to download video from the url and
then we have to have a file name so to
get the file name dynamically we are
going to use the url title
for the file name which is also present
in here and then the final step we are
again going to use
get request
to extract the content of the url
which is currently the mp4 file and then
we are going to use
that content to write
using f dot write and then we are going
to save in the output file so as you
might have seen this is the mp4 file
which should end with dot mp4 which we
extracted from here this part
and then we are going to use f dot write
to write the content of the mp4 file in
the output file that we wanted which is
an mp4 file and then we are going to
print a message that the download
process is finished so in this video we
learned how to build the entire code a
generic first version of the code that
will help us in downloading the mp4
video of a ted x update video from
ted.com using request and bs4 thank you
for listening in the next video we'll
see how to generalize this code so that
it can be packaged as a cli tool
that anyone can pass a url instead of
hard coding it and then download the
video
in this video we'll see
how to generalize the code that we built
using the last video
for a better cli tool so what do i mean
by a cli tool a cli tool is nothing but
you can have a package the code that we
developed
as one line
in your terminal and then you can get
the output
of that without having the need of
entering you know your pycharm or
without having the need of editing the
code so as you might have seen in the
last video we actually hard coded the
url we gave the url as part of the code
but that is not going to help us in long
term because not every time you want to
open a text editor enter the url and
then recompile the entire um execute the
entire python code so for that purpose
what we are going to do is we are going
to generalize this code
and as we saw in the last video that is
exactly why we are going to use this
particular module of python which is cis
so first we need to
check whether someone is giving a
particular url as part of the
execution command so for that we are
going to include this exception handling
module in the code exception is nothing
but unexpected error so that's why we
are calling it exception handling how to
handle the exception so in this section
what we are doing is we are checking cis
dot rv r stands for argument that is
passed
with the code execution so we are seeing
if the length of cis dot rb is more than
one then we take the first argument that
is passed with the code execution else
we are going to pass this message sys
dot exist
exit message that says error please
enter the ted talk url
to demonstrate the output of this let us
go to terminal let us take the code that
we saved using the previous section and
then we'll use python3 and then type
this and see what is the error that you
are getting the error that you are
getting is error please enter the ted
talk url so that is exactly what is
happening here so we have written this
exception handling module that will tell
us error please enter the ted talk url
which will show up when someone is just
executing the name executing the file
name without passing any argument which
is what we are checking here so to check
how the code executes properly let us
actually take a proper url
of ted talk and then we will see how to
download this entire video as this is
becoming a cli tool now let us save this
code let us copy this video url that we
just used uh hardcoded in the previous
uh
video so now we'll go to terminal we'll
do the same python three
date talk downloader and then we'll
paste the video you are the actual data
url and let us press enter and as you
can see these are the messages that we
have given in the previous
uh section download about the start and
then download has started we extracted
the url name and then storing in this
particular name and then it says
download process finished at the start
of this video you might have seen that
we had only four files in this
particular video in this particular
folder but now
as we do ls you can actually see we have
one extra file which is an mp4 file
which is what we have downloaded let us
go into our finder and see so we had all
these four files and now as part of this
thing
we have this file also so which is
actually a ted talk
so what we have seen is
we actually built a first draft code
first version of the code that did not
have argument parsing where we hard
coded the url in this video we learned
how to generalize this video generalize
this code
which will include url as part of an
argument and that url will be used to
download the video and we also saw how
to handle the exception when someone is
not giving the url as part of the
execution in the terminal
thank you for listening
in this section we'll learn how to build
a table extractor from the pdf file
format pdf is one of the most prevalent
file formats that we deal with in our
daily life anyone who works in data
science would know that extracting table
from pdfs is one of the most boring
manual tasks than one have to deal with
in this section we'll start with basics
of pdf file format then we'll learn how
to install the required python modules
for extracting the pdf then we'll
actually do the coding part to extract
table from pdf then finally we'll learn
a bit about pandas data frame and then
using pandas data frame to write the
table that we just extracted into a csv
file
thank you
in the next video we'll start with
basics of pdf file format
in this video we'll learn the basics of
pdf file format pdf stands for portable
document format which is a file format
developed by adobe in the 1990s this
file format was developed to present
documents that include text graphics and
images
independent of the software and hardware
and operating systems as same
let us say whether it is apple mac or
microsoft windows a document should look
the same in both the operating systems
and both the hardwares hence pdf was
developed
the first version 1.0 of pdf was
introduced in 1993 pdf is based on the
postscript language
each pdf file encapsulates a complete
description of a fixed layout flat
document
the way the text and graphics are
embedded on the pdf are based on the
layout not with any structured format
the general structure of a pdf file is
composed of four main components header
body
cross reference table trailer
the header contains just one line that
identifies the version of the pdf for
example percentage pdf 1.5 this
indicates that this pdf belongs to the
version 1.5
the trailer contains pointers to the
cross reference table and to key objects
contained in the trailer dictionary it
ends with percentage percentage eof to
identify endo file eof
stands for end of file the cross
reference table contains
pointers to all the objects included in
the pdf it identifies how many objects
are in the table where the objects begin
and its length in bytes the body
contains all the object information for
example object informations like fonts
images words bookmarks form fields and
so on so these objects are mapped using
the cross reference table and then thus
this forms the structure of the pdf so
far in this video we learned the basics
of a pdf file format and the general
structure of a pdf file in the next
video we'll learn how to install the
required python packages for this
project
in this video we'll learn how to install
the required python packages for this
project so we need three python packages
for this particular project the first
one is jupiter the second one is camelot
and then the third one is shebond which
we are going to use for data
visualization so to install jupyter
notebook we have to open our terminal
and then use the jupyter notebook
installation command before that let us
see a bit about jupyter notebook jupyter
notebook is an open source web
application that allows you to create
and share documents that contain live
code visualization and narrative text so
jupyter notebook is one of the most
preferred ides or notebooks used in data
science community and the reason is
jupyter notebook lets you write code and
also the narrative takes in the form of
markdown in the same file format
also jupyter notebook let says
upload jupyter notebook's rendered file
which is a markdown on web so if you are
going to maintain a web blog which is
marked on base so you can export jupyter
notebook's markdown file and then upload
it on web alternatively if you want a
python file not a jupyter notebook just
a python file to share it with your ps
or automation then jupyter notebook also
lets you download the file that you have
written the notebook file into dot pi
format so let us go ahead and then
install jupyter notebook open your shell
or terminal
where you would be doing this
installation if you are using mac open
your terminal and if you are using
windows open your command prompt so once
you open your command prompt as we have
seen in the previous videos if you have
python 3 then you have to type pip3 for
installation of any python package and
then type install and jupyter
once you type enter this command will
install jupyter notebook on our machine
so it seems that jupyter notebook has
been installed so let us validate
whether jupyter notebook has been
successfully installed so let us type
jupyter
notebook enter to invoke the jupyter
notebook as you can see jupyter notebook
has been successfully installed now for
us to shut down this notebook let us go
to the terminal and then type control c
so type control c in your keyboard to
shut down this jupyter notebook and it
asks you whether you want to shut down
press y that the jupyter notebook has
been successfully shut down so you can
see the shutdown confirmation so the
next package that we would like to
install is
camelot camelot is the python package
that we would be using to extract tables
from pdf
camelot is an open source package that
is available on pipeline so the same way
that we installed jupyter notebook we
can use pip to install camelot
camelot is the package that we have
preferred in this project to extract
table from pdfs so let us go ahead and
then install camelot package
so now once i can type pip3
install
camelot but the thing with the camelot
package is instead of just typing
camelot you need to install camelot pi
the reason is there is already a python
package in the name of camelot which is
not this package so these package
developers decided to put it in the name
camelot hyphen py so the package that we
should be installing is camelot dash py
even though the package name is camelot
we have to install it like this so let
us type enter
that the package gets installed on a
local machine so we see that the package
has been installed so let us verify
whether camelot has been installed
successfully so let us open our python
client ripple once we have python client
let us try to import camelot
so camelot has been successfully
imported without any error which means
camelot has been successfully installed
so let us exit the python console
and then the next package that we are
interested in is c bond c bond is the
package that we are going to use for
data visualization so as part of this
project once we extract the table from
the pdf we are going to visualize it so
that the data science workflow is
completed so cbon is the package that we
would be installing so let us install c1
let us go ahead and open our terminal
let's clear the screen and then type pip
3 install c bond
once you type enter c bond is going to
get installed so c bond ultimately
requires matplotlib asset dependency so
if you have got matplotlib already on
your machine so cbon wouldn't install it
again but if you have not got it no
problem matplotlib would also get
installed on your machine so let us
clear the terminal and then verify
whether c bond has been successfully
installed so open python 3
import c bond
as you can see c1 has been successfully
imported which means c bond installation
is successful so in this video we have
seen that we installed the required
python packages we installed three
packages which are jupiter for jupyter
notebook camelot for extracting table
from pdf and then cbone for data
visualization so in the next video we'll
start with the coding of how to extract
table from the pdf thank you for
listening
in this video we'll learn how to extract
table from a pdf file before we start
with the coding part let us try to
understand what other python modules are
available for the same purpose the first
one is tabula tabula is one of the most
widely used pdf extraction library
tabula is actually based on a java
library in the same name tabula so this
one that we are talking about is a
python binding for the java library
the next one is pdf plumber then pdf
tables and pdf table extract so all
these libraries are available as an
alternate for the library that we have
picked for this particular project so
even though all these libraries are
available we have selected camelot to go
ahead with so the reason we selected
camelot is because of the following
reasons the first main reason is you are
in control so unlike other libraries and
tools which give you a nice output or
fail miserably so there is no in between
so either it gives you a nice output or
it fails miserably
camelot gives you the power to tweak the
table extraction with hyper parameters
which means if you do not get any output
then you can tweak your hyper parameters
to get at least some output so that not
everything in the pdf table extraction
becomes manual the reason is because
since everything in the real world
is actually fuzzy including pdf table
extraction is also fuzzy you need to
have control over the hyper parameters
to tweak how you want to extract the
table from the pdf the second one is bad
tables can be discarded based on the
metrics like accuracy and white space so
camelot gives you these metrics accuracy
and white space so that you don't have
to manually look at each table to select
the good table and discard the bad table
the next reason is the table output that
you get out of camelot is a pandas data
frame pandas data frame is one of the
most widely used python module for data
analysis and data science which means
the output of the camelot library could
be seamlessly integrated into any etl
workflow or a data analysis workflow
which existingly uses camelot or python
the last reason is because camelot lets
you export the extracted pdf table into
multiple file formats including json
excel and html let us say that the table
that you extracted from the pdf file
format you wanted it to be published
online which means you ultimately want a
html file format so instead of sitting
and hard coding a html file format a
table html table camelot lets you export
the pdf table that you just extracted
into a html file so this way camelot
helps you with
being in control discarding bad tables
and then using a pandas data frame which
is easily seamlessly integrated with an
existing data analysis workflow and then
finally exporting that file format into
a different file format so this is the
reason why we picked camelot ahead of
the other packages that we just
mentioned so let us move ahead and then
learn how camelot is going to help us in
extracting tables from pdf the pdf from
which we would like to extract data is
this pdf this has been downloaded from
uin website which is economic and human
development indicators for india so this
is a fact sheet with multiple tables as
you can see you have one table here you
have another table here so multiple
tables with multiple columns so for this
particular purpose we are interested in
extracting the values row 20 21 and 22
of this table which is literacy rate so
let us go ahead and see how we we are
going to extract this particular table
and then do a little bit of data
visualization with this
before we move on to the actual coding
because this is the first time we are
going to use jupyter notebook in our
course so let us see a bit of overview
about jupyter notebook so open your
terminal which is windows command prompt
or mac terminal and type jupyter
notebook once you type jupyter notebook
it would internally work a server and
then your jupyter notebook
which this interface would open and then
for you to create a new jupyter notebook
click here new and then type python3
click this python 3. so once you enter
here this is how the structure of a
jupyter notebook would look like so this
is the title which you can edit to say
okay my first jupyter notebook
so once we have renamed it this is how
the jupyter notebook would look like so
this in the jupyter notebook would be
called as a cell this cell can have
primarily two values so it can have a
code value where you can write your
python code or it can have a markdown
where you write your narrative text or
documentation so let us start with the
documentation and say
this is my first jupyter notebook
and then let's say this is a heading so
once you are done with this thing this
is how it looks like so now let us go
ahead and write a small python code
as you all know python can be also used
as a calculator which means you can do
basic arithmetic operation so let us go
ahead and do a little bit of arithmetic
operation which says three into three
once you are done with this code you can
press shift enter
like this and then the output would be
displayed or maybe if you do not want to
use the keyboard shortcut you can say
okay four minus three which is probably
one and then we'll go ahead and click
run button here which will show us
output one so this way you know that you
can have
documentation or narrative text and then
code in the same file and then this is
the advantage of jupyter notebook and
one of the reasons why we prefer jupyter
notebook for this particular project now
let us go ahead and start executing the
actual code that we would like to write
for extracting table from the un report
that we just saw so to start with we
should name the jupiter notebook which
is a good practice so in this case we
can name it extracting
table from pdf so whatever you would
like to name you can name it so i've
named it extracting table from pdf the
first cell let us start with importing
the camelot package in this case i'm
importing the camelot package with an
alias which is cm which will help us
easily call that evoke that package so
let us go here and say shift enter once
the jupyter notebook successfully
install you get this thing probably
let's say if you have made a mistake
instead of camelot you have said
cam as cm
now you would get an error that this
module is not found because there is no
such package cam in this particular
python environment so once we
successfully
invoke or call that package we will not
get any error but the package has been
imported so next step is for us to see
what are all the files available in the
environment so we see these are the
files that we have in that environment
so we have the pdf
file that is available in the current
folder we have the csv and xls which i
just executed before the
project and i have it in place
and then we have a bunch of other files
so now let us go ahead and then import
the file there are two ways that you can
read pdf one you can read it directly
from web like from where we have
downloaded the pdf or you can read it
from your local machine so the first
argument is you read
you give the python
the pdf file name
the second argument is flavor which is
there are two ways camelot can parse
your pdf file one is called stream the
other one is called letters both these
have different variety of ways to how to
parse a pdf file and in this particular
case we will prefer
lattice and then we are explicitly
telling camelot that we have two pages
one is page one the second one is page
two so we are going to use the function
name
read underscore pdf from camelot and
then we are going to read the pdf file
so let us execute this shift enter
once we execute this thing
we are writing it in the python object
input underscore pdf so we can see that
this has been successfully executed
without any error so now let us see what
is inside that input underscore pdf so
this gives you a table list object with
four values inside it which means there
are four tables that has been extracted
from this function from this pdf and
this has been put inside this into input
underscore pdf as a table file so for us
to know what are the individual
properties individual dimensions of this
particular pdf
extraction process we will see for n in
input underscore pdf so we are iterating
in through input underscore pdf to see
what is inside it so let us go ahead and
execute this thing so this shows that we
have four pdf table extracted files
which is first one is the table is with
the dimension four by three which means
four rows three columns second one is
fifteen by three the third one is
fourteen by four and then the fourth one
is thirteen by three so our area of
interest is the last part of the first
page as you saw in the previous pdf
display so we are going to say okay i
want this third one since python is a
zero index language we will say two
input underscore pdf of two and then we
are saying give me it as a data frame
so once we write this thing this is what
we get
as you can see this is our area of
interest which is the literacy rate and
which is the index value 11 12 and 13.
so what we are going to do now is we are
going to say okay i want
input underscore pdf of 2 and then from
that i want the data frame and in that
give me the location 11 to 14 and then
give me three columns which is one two
three so i want 1 2 3 11 12 13 that is
what we are specifying here once we
execute this thing we can see how the
data frame looks like so this is how the
extractor table looks like so let us do
a little bit of table formatting before
we do table formatting we have
understood that
this data frame that camelot gives us is
part of a pandas data frame so let us
have a little bit of understanding of
pandas pandas is the data manipulation
package that is widely used the most
widely used for python and pandas helps
you read a csv write a csv read in excel
write in excel do a little bit of
reformatting in case if you want to you
know do a little bit of data analysis
pandas will help you do data preparation
data preprocessing so like that what we
are going to do is we are going to use a
pandas function which is reset index to
drop this index value 11 12 and 3 and
then come up with our own index value
which is by default 0 1 2 3
so let us go ahead say okay for this
data frame
dot reduce reset underscore index drop
is equal to true and then we will assign
it to the data frame here so let us go
ahead and execute this thing
and then let's see how the output looks
like so now as you can see from 11 12 13
it has become 0 1 2 now as you can see
there are three columns but the column
names are 1 2 3 which is not very
intuitive if you want to write a table
so what we will do is we'll manually put
the table name so from the table you can
you can see that this is 2001 this is
2011 and these are the kps that we are
interested in so what we'll do is we'll
say okay the first column is kpa second
is 2001. third is 2011. let us execute
this thing and then let us see how the
output looks like so from one two three
now it has become kpa 2001 and 2011.
then the next step is for us to do any
kind of data analysis with this thing we
need to convert this one which is
actually a string into a number format
and the number format that we are going
to use is float because this is a
decimal point so from string we are
going to say for 2001 and 2011
convert everything to float so once we
do this thing
we are reassigning it to the same old
data frame and then the output even
though it looks same internally from
string it has become a character the
next step is for us to write
the output as a csv file so
because this file name was already
available we'll say
packed output dot csv so once we have
written the csv we can go ahead and see
using ls command to see
how the current working directory looks
like so as you can see we have packed
underscore output.csv which is what we
just wrote using pandas function which
is to underscore csv once we are done
with this thing i would like to add
another information that pandas is not
just letting you write it as a csv but
it can help you write it as an excel
file so let us go ahead and then use
this function
to underscore excel on this pandas data
frame to write it as an excel
let's say part output
excel
with the extension dot xlsx
and then once we execute this thing let
us see how the current directory looks
like so in the previous setup you had
only packed underscore output.csv but
now you can also see that
at underscore output underscore
excel dot xlsx so this is how the excel
file looks like so as we write it so now
what we can do is we would like to
import this in our current working
directory in this current python session
so that we can do some data analysis so
our objective in this project is to read
table and then write that output table
as a csv which we have already achieved
but as a bonus i would like to also show
you why we would be requiring such a
data frame in the first place because we
want to do some data analysis some data
visualization from the pdf file which we
cannot do it directly so we are
extracting the table from the pdf as a
csv as a data frame which is then we are
converting it as a csv and then we are
doing some data analysis with this in
this case we will build a bar graph with
this so let us go ahead and call our
pandas data frame which is required for
us to read the csv
so as we call the pandas data frame
we'll say pd dot read underscore csv and
what is the name of the file that we
wrote it is packed underscore output dot
csv so we'll replace this name with this
name
and then we'll say read underscore csv
and then we are assigning it to a python
object which is df2 and then we'll
display how it looks like so once we
execute this thing we can see this is
how it looks like with an index value
because we just
read it
then we'll call the data visualization
library c1 c1 is one of the most widely
used data visualization library c bond
is actually built on matplotlib for
better visualizations so we'll go ahead
and call c bond with an arias sns
once we are done with that
executed c bond is now imported so for
us to build the data visualization we
have to change the format the shape of
how the data frame looks like to a
different shape so we are going to use
the pandas function milt which will
convert this data frame from the void
format to a long format so this is
called to be a wide format now we are
going to convert it to a long format now
let us execute this thing once we
execute
df underscore melt is available now let
us see how df underscore melt is
available so as you can see
this is a wide format now this is a long
format frame where 2001 and 2011 from
being the column name that has become
the row value and the value that we have
given is year and percentage
now the df underscore melted is
available let us go ahead and then make
a bar plot so we are going to use sns
dot bar plot for making a bar plot the x
axis should contain the kpa value the y
axis should contain the percentage and
the hue which is the grouping variable
which is 2011 and 2001 for us to compare
how it has been different for 2011 and
then 2001.
let us execute this thing as you can see
now it has generated a plot with
two bars the blue color represent 2001
the orange color represents 2011 and
then with three kps that we just built
literacy rate male literacy rate or
female literacy rate so this is how the
overall literacy rate and as you can see
the gap between 2001 and 2011 female
literacy rate is huge which means there
has been a tremendous growth between
2001 and 2011 in the rate of female
literacy rate so this is what we have
understood from this project that we had
a raw pdf file which was unreadable
as it is not a structured information
what we have done is we have used
camelot to read the pdf which is to be
technical we parsed the pdf we extracted
tables specifically we extracted four
tables we went to the table of our
interest which is
index 11 12 and 3 and then we did a
little bit of data preprocessing using
pandas once we did the data
preprocessing we went ahead and then we
wrote
the data frame into a csv file and we
also experimented with writing it as an
excel file
once we were done with this excel file
we finally went and did a little bit of
data pre-processing which is reshaping
the data from a wide format to long
format and then finally we explored the
data as a data visualization to
understand
some valuable insight from the pdf that
we have written so far in this video
tutorial we learned how to build a table
extractor from pdf so we started with
understanding the pdf file formats then
we went ahead and installed camelot and
jupyter notebook python packages then we
understood how to extract pdf table and
then we saw basics of pandas data frame
to write and read csv and then we went
ahead with c bond to do some
visualization so at the end of this
project we have a successful
visualization we have the output table
as csv and excel and then we also
learned how to extract table from any
pdf so thank you for listening i'll see
you in the next section
in this section we'll learn how to build
an automated bulk resume parser going
through resumes and extracting relevant
information from those resumes is one of
the most essential tasks a manager has
to go through before hiring new
resources in this section we'll learn
how to build an automated bulk resume
parser that can go through multiple
resumes and extract relevant information
from them and convert them into a
structured tabular format with a click
of a button we'll start this section
by understanding different formats of
resumes and marking relevant information
that we would like to extract
a brief overview of packages and the
installation of those packages then
we'll see the basics of regular
expression in python and also the basic
overview of spacey functions and then
we'll move on to build the code to
extract relevant information and then
finally we'll complete the script to
make it one click command level tool
let us go ahead and then see the
sections
in this video we'll learn the different
formats of resumes and then we'll mark
essential information that we would like
to extract in this project so as you can
see on my screen i've got two different
types of resumes the first one
is
a single column which has content one by
one and then the second one is a double
column which means in one page they have
got two columns and then the experiences
and other details are scattered across
the columns
so as you can see a resume can of be
multiple types so it is up to the
creator of the resume
essentially the one who is seeking for a
job to have the format that he or she
likes but it is essential for the
recruiting manager to completely go
through the resume to extract essential
parts of it so what do we mean by
essential parts the first one is i would
say that the name
the name to whom this resume belongs is
the most essential part because if you
ever want to shortlist this resume you
need to understand who is that person
and then the second thing is if you ever
want to shortlist a resume you just do
not want to know there is name but also
you need to be able to contact them and
then the two key information to contact
a person
one their email id and then the second
one their phone number so as you can see
in this resume the name is first of all
mentioned in the top left but in this
resume the name is in the center
position and in this resume the email id
is in the top right but in this resume
it is all centrally aligned so as you
can see
we have totally listed down three
elements the first one is name the
second one is email id and then the
third one is a phone number these are
the three information significant
information that we would like to
extract from this resume but more than
this what we want to do is we want to
have a criteria
for which we want to extract this resume
which means for example let us say you
are recruiting for a position
called data scientist and for a position
called data scientist you need to have
relevant resumes who have the essential
skills of a data scientist and that is
the most important information that we
would like to see in the resume
extraction project so for that purpose
we are going to extract skills from this
resume especially to say technical
skills so the things that we are going
to extract is most importantly the
technical skills from the resume then
the name
phone number
email id irrespective of how or where
these informations are present in a
particular resume we are going to
extract this information using this
particular project
before we move on we have to also
understand one more thing that resume
itself is a file and then the file could
have multiple formats for example a
resume could be a simple image of jpeg
or png the resume could be a docx which
is microsoft word or the resume could be
of pdf in this particular project we are
going to only deal with the resumes of
pdf type because
once we have written a script for pdf
file format it is not very tough for you
to convert every other format into a pdf
format
let's say you can convert a jpeg to a
pdf format you can convert a docx to a
pdf format so that is one of the reasons
why we have picked pdf format as
one
condition
where we will build this project upon so
pdf is the file format that we are going
to use and also that we are going to use
resumes of different types it could be
single or double column and then the
informations that we are going to
extract a skill
name
email id and phone number
in the next video we will see the
architecture of this project and then
the required python modules and how to
install those python modules
in this video we'll see the
architectural overview of this project
so in this project we'll take three pdf
files so resumes in three pdf files and
we'll store it in a local folder so what
we are going to do is we are going to
take
one pdf file from this folder and then
we will convert this pdf into text and
then we will do natural language
processing and pattern matching to
extract relevant information that are
required the relevant information that
we saw in the previous video which are
name
email id phone number and skills and
then we'll use these relevant
information to populate a structured
tabular format
and then finally we'll write the output
in a csv format meanwhile while we are
doing pdf to text we also would save
those pdf files as text files for future
reference we'll iterate these process
until all the files in the current
directory which is the folder
are completed
so to repeat we are going to take pdf
files
convert them into pdf to text then do
natural language processing and pattern
matching and then we are going to
populate them in a structured tabular
format and then we are going to write it
in a csv so for this purpose these are
the packages that we are going to use
the first one is pdf miner for pdf to
text then spacey for natural language
processing then re rejects package that
is for pattern matching
and pandas for output csv
saving
meanwhile we also would use another
package called os this is for operating
system manipulation which is highly
required for us to iterate through
multiple files and in the current
working directory and also to save the
output files in the required folder
so the packages that we would be using
are pdf miner spacey
re os and pandas so of all these five
packages packages re and os come by
default installed on your python
operating system
so of all these five packages
packages re and os are already installed
by default in your python environment so
it is required for us to install pdf
miner spacey and pandas
as we just saw of the five required
python packages two packages come by
default with your python installation
those are re and os
so we'll go ahead and see how to install
the rest of the packages which is pdf
miner spacey and pandas to start with
pdf miner is the package that we are
going to use to convert a pdf into text
and the package that we are going to use
is called pdf miner.6 for that reason is
because
pdf miner is the actual package name
whose development stopped before python
2.7 so there was a requirement to
support the latest version of python and
that is where this fork as you can see
this is a 4 of pdf miner and this is
called pdf miner.6
so anytime you're going to deal with pdf
and then you want the pdf to be
converted into a text format and then
you have got python version which is
latest mostly 3
then you have to install pdf miner.6 not
pdf miner
so as we have always seen how to install
a python package
in this project also we'll use a
terminal a shell or command prompt and
then we'll use pip to install the
required python package so let us open
our terminal or in case if you have got
windows machine command prompt and type
pip3
install pdf miner
dot six
so as i have got already this package on
my machine this is successfully shown
that it has been satisfied now let us
open our python terminal
to see if pdf miner has been
successfully installed so let us try
import pdf miner
you can notice this difference that when
we install the package it is called pdf
minor dot six but when we import it it
is as same as pdf minor so the only
reason they have got this dot six is to
differentiate between the older version
of pdf miner and the newer version of
pdf miner so let us type pdf import pdf
miner and then
press enter and then you can see that it
has been successfully imported without
any error which means pdf miner has been
successfully imported
the next python package that we would
like to install is spacey spacey is the
library that we are going to use for
natural language processing in fact
spacey is one of the most popular
natural language processing libraries in
python and it is widely used in the
industry for natural language processing
there are a lot of features of spacey
for example the tokenization is very
good it has got a good named entity
recognition it has got a very good
language support like 49 languages are
supported it also comes with pre-trained
models which helps us do a lot of
natural language processing without
training our own model
so let us go ahead and install spacey so
to install spacey we can see that again
we will use pip and then we'll do
install spacey and if you remember one
of the things that i've told from our
previous sections we use pip3 because a
python version is python 3. in case if
you have got
python you have to use pip so pip3
install spacey
so as you can see requirement is already
satisfied because i've got this package
already so it has been successfully
installed let us clear our terminal and
then open python 3 to see if
spacey has been successfully installed
so python 3 import spacey
yeah spacey has been successfully
imported let us exit but there is one
more thing that we have to do with
respect to spacey which is download the
language model so natural language
processing can work better only if the
language model is available which
usually has got all these words and then
the part of speech the named entity
recognition all this stuff so for us to
download the
default
language model english language model
for spacey we have to use this command
which will put in our terminal
and because we have got python3 will do
python3
spacey
download so once this is successfully
done our language model is successfully
installed so we can see that the
language model has been installed and
then it is also telling us that the way
we have load our language model is
spacey dot load the language model so
let us
just check that once
let us open our python terminal
and then say import spacey
and then copy this
and then say okay my nlp is equal to
yeah the language model has been
successfully loaded which means we have
got successfully installed spacey and
that language model that is required for
us to do english natural language
processing and then the final library
that we are going to install is pandas
pandas is the library the go to library
for any
tabular data manipulation and pandas is
one of the most widely used library in
data science for data manipulation so it
is much easier for us to install pandas
as the name suggests we'll do let's
clear terminal tip 3 install pandas
we can see that the requirement has been
satisfied let us open our python
terminal and say import pandas
so pandas has been successfully imported
without any error which means
we have successfully installed the
packages that are required for us which
is pdf miner and then spacey
and then
pandas but we also saw that there are
other two libraries that comes by
default
in the current python installation that
we have got so let us just verify
whether those packages are available so
the first package that we saw is
re which is for regular express
manipulation so we'll do import re
yeah it's been successfully imported and
then the next package that we saw is os
for operating system manipulation to you
know find files
pass through folders so we'll do import
os
and as we can see these two libraries
are successfully imported which means we
are all set with all the libraries that
are required for us to proceed with this
project and then
we'll see how to code in the next
section we'll see
basics of regular expression and natural
language processing overview and then
we'll move on to coding
thank you
in this video we learn basics of regular
expression regular expression could be
also called as rejects or
x or reg x so whatever you would like to
call it is a sequence of characters that
define a search pattern that search
pattern is usually the combination of
characters and meta characters so the
meta characters are like this
cap
dollar dot pipe or curly braces so these
meta characters define the syntax around
characters to create the search pattern
which is what we call as regular
expression
regular expression
is one of the
toughest
programming concepts that is not very
familiar so there are a lot of memes
around uh regular expressions on
internet you can just refer to it to see
how tough it is so just to understand
regular expression we'll go through
little bit basics but uh regular
expression is so old that anytime you
google for regular expression you would
find the answer for which you are
searching for so the basics of relay
expression is
primarily to understand the meta
characters
the meta character pipe the pipe
operator
defines the boolean or so if you want to
compare between two words whether it is
g r a y or g r e y then you would use a
pipe operator in your regular expression
so then parenthesis let us assume that
you do not want to use individual
different words but you want to just use
r for one particular character then you
would use g r
open parenthesis a pipe e close
paranthesis which is to say i want gr
and then it could be either a or e and
then i want y so this is how my pattern
should look like
and this is what we call as grouping
regular expression meta characters also
has something called quantification
which is to say
how many or how
the number of elements or tokens should
be present in the pattern that i would
like to see for example the question
mark indicates
zero or one occurrence of the preceding
element which means
let us say you have got color c o l o u
question mark and r which means
it could
match both c o l o r r c o l o u are
while question mark is about only one
occurrence asterisk which is star is
about multiple occurrences
which means if you say a b star c
it could be either
a b c or it could be either a b b c or
it could be either a b b b c or so on so
it doesn't
strictly count to only one occurrence of
the preceding character but it actually
has n number of preceding characters
that you could have but the condition is
that you have to have a
and b and c
so this is the basic concept of regular
expression but you could actually refer
more online to understand more of
regular expression but for us to proceed
with this project i think this is good
enough for us to see
how to build a basic regular expression
or at least to understand the regular
expression that we might get from
internet
so now from the basics of regular
expression as such we'll move forward to
see how these regular expressions could
be used in python for us to do pattern
matching and as we saw in the previous
video the package that we are going to
use for regular expression in python is
re so
re has these major functions match
search
find all split sub and compile so of
these you would see compile is something
that would be mostly used to create a
regular expression and then compile it
and then use that compiled regular
expression
to
find and search for everything else
and match
is when you would use if you want to
match the first word and search you
don't care about whether it is first or
second word but you would want to find
it anywhere it isn't and find all again
it has its own purpose so let us open
our terminal and then see a little bit
of regular expression how we would like
to do it so you can open either your
terminal or your python console on
pycharm or jupyter notebook but for
simplicity i'm just invoking python from
my terminal
then say import
ie
and let us create a sample text okay my
text is going to say best python
course this is my text and now i would
like to see where the word based
if the word best occurs
in my text so first i'm going to say re
dot match
of paste which is my search pattern here
in this case a regular expression
comma
i'm going to save my text
and then enter so as you can see it has
replied with a re-object under span 0 to
4 which means i've got the word best
and the match is best
but let us say we want to test it with
two different words either best
or
let's say good
match but we are going to use pipe
operator to say good
so it says the match is best because the
text is saying we have got best python
course let us create a second text which
is text two and in this case we'll say
good python course
and then we'll use the same regular
expression that we used before which is
best pipe good which means either best
or good and then say text 2.
in this case it says that it has matched
with good and then it is the same space
now what we'll do is instead of using
match
in this
we'll use good best python course as
text to
and then instead of using match we'll
use search to see
what output it gives us
as you can see
it has matched
good
because we have got either best or good
and then in text two and the position is
good best python course let us assume
now we want to see both both of these in
the given text so now we'll say
redot
find
all which will result as both good and
best so in this case we wanted to see
whether both these words are present and
then because both these words are
present it is returning us both good and
best that it is present in the
text and in case if the pattern that we
have given the regular expression that
we have given is let's say something
like this and then it is not available
and then we will not get any result
which is we have got an empty list so
these are the main functions that we are
going to use in this particular project
so
this is a very brief introduction
of regular expression and also how to
use regular expression in python for
pattern matching
in the next video we'll see very basics
of natural language processing using
spacey
in this video we'll learn basics of
natural language processing using spacey
so let us open our jupyter notebook and
create a new jupyter notebook so you can
do this by going to file
and then new notebook and select python
3. once you have this new notebook let
us now see a little bit about spacey so
as we saw in the previous video spacey
is one of the most popular used
natural language processing library so
we'll import the library using import
spacey
once that is done the very first step
the next step that we are supposed to do
is
load our language model so if you
remember after installing spacey library
we downloaded the english language model
so if you remember after installing
spacey python library we actually
downloaded the english language model
because a language model is essential
for a lot of natural language processing
tasks
so we are going to load the language
model that we downloaded in the previous
section so we will use spacey.load and
then
put the name of the language model that
you have downloaded for example let us
assume that you have downloaded a
language model for a different language
like german so you will have a different
name instead of en so in that case put
the language model name that you have
downloaded and then assign it to nlp so
once this is successfully executed
now what you can do is you can define
the text that you have so the text that
i've got is i've got a couple of
sentences from google wikipedia page for
us to explore this package so i'm going
to use this as text and then i'm
assigning it to text so if you print
text you will see okay this is my text
so what are we going to do now is now
that the entire thing is ready so we
have imported the package we have loaded
the language model and then the input
text on which we have to do natural
language processing is ready so the
first step in a natural language
processing is annotation so what you're
going to do is you're going to let the
language model annotate your input text
so that the input text is created in
such a way that it knows what is a part
of speech tagging in it it knows where
are the
named entity recognition it tokenizes it
it creates word vectors it can do a lot
of other things
so the first step is use the language
model because you loaded the language
model and assign it to nlp on
the text input text that you have got so
the way you do is nlp of text and then
you store the result in doc so once you
store the result in doc the first very
first step that any natural language
processing would require you to do is
tokenization what is tokenization
tokenization is nothing but splitting
the input text based on a token so for
example so in this case what we are
going to do is we are going to split the
entire text word by word so word is the
token for us here so you can do the
sentence organization you can do this
even paragraph organization but in this
case we are going to do word
tokenization
so say
we have got doc so let us print how the
dock looks like
once i print dock
i'm not getting anything other than this
thing because this is what it is
printing but internally doc has been
annotated using the natural language
processing library and language model
that we have got so what are we going to
do is we are going to say for token and
dock print token so we are going to
iterate through dock and then say ok
print each and every token by default
which is a word token so we what we see
is we see one by one word by word and
then okay this the word tokenization has
been successfully done once the word
tokenization has been successfully done
we can do a lot of things for example
you can build a word claudio if you want
you can build a unigram or if you want
you can have a bigram also combining the
words
in case let's say you want to visualize
the sentence instead of doing word
tokenization you can do a sentence
tokenization so the opportunities are
lot so you can do anything you want
to move ahead with the spacey library
what we can further do is as we saw when
you annotate your input text using the
language model that you have got you get
part of speech also part of speeches to
say okay this this word is a noun this
word is a verb this word is an adjective
so all these things so what we are going
to do now is we are going to say okay
for token and dock the same thing that
we saw before
but we are saying only if
the token dot pos underscore which is to
say that this is a part of speech which
is noun then print the token so print
all the tokens which is known that is
what we are going to do here so you see
that you have got founder money money
angel all these things let us say
instead of non let's say we want work so
once you execute this you get was funded
but in case if you want adjective you
put adj and then you get all the
adjectives that you have got so this is
how you extract a particular part of
speech for example you're doing text
summarization or you're doing any other
text technique you want to extract topic
from it so you're going to only go for
nouns and adjectives so the same way for
you to identify a particular part of
speech so this is what you're going to
use iterate through the document for
every token you're going to say give me
the part of speech
so the next important thing or in fact
the most important thing for this
particular project is named entity
recognition so what is named entity
recognition named entity recognition is
nothing but identifying an entity of
that particular word for example google
is an organization august 1998 is a date
when you have money dollars it is money
when you see a person's name it is a
person so identifying you know putting a
context around the word instead of just
simply saying whether it is a
grammatically noun or verb or adverb
adjective so you are trying to say okay
this is what i have identified this
entity so this is what we are calling us
named entity recognition and this is
much much easier to do in spacey because
of the language model that we have got
and spacey has made it so easy for us to
do it in one single function so what we
are going to do is
we are going to say doc dot ins which
will apply the entity recognition on the
dock so in the previous section you
would have seen that we have done it
only on doc because we were iterating
through the actual words but in this
case we want to iterate through the
entities so we are saying doc dot ends
which is for entities and then we are
iterating over it with entity and then
we are saying okay print entity dot text
the actual word and then print entity
dot label underscore which means the
label of the entity that has been
recognized so i'm printing the word and
i'm printing the
label of the entity which is
organization or date or whatever it is
so once i print this thing this is what
i get
so once i print this thing so we have
entity.text ntt.label underscore i'm
going to print this and once i print
this thing and this is what i get so i
get a google org or augustus august 1998
is a date and google is again
organization jeff bezos ceo of amazon is
a person and then stanford university is
an organization so this is the way what
we are going to do is we are going to
take the text and then identify
important entities that are present in
this text so this is the basic overview
of natural language processing using
spacey of course natural language
processing is an emerging area in
research and development and of course
one of the most widely you know
anticipated areas in machine learning
and artificial intelligence so learning
natural language processing with just
five sales in jupiter notebook is
completely impossible but just wanted to
give you a flavor of what we might be
doing in this course so that you have
some idea of you know how to proceed
further or if you want to extend this
particular project to include different
set of skills
a different
variables that we have not captured in
this resume parsing project so you can
use this understanding that we have
covered in this video to extend this
particular project to you know a wider
objective so in this video we
successfully learned the basics of
natural language processing using spacey
we saw a couple of species functions how
to load spacey how to load natural
language processing the library english
language library and then we also saw a
little bit about tokenization and named
recognition in the next video we will
actually start with the coding part of
resume parsing project which we are
entered to do in this particular project
in this video we will learn how to code
the actual project of resume parsing
before we get into coding there is a
little bit of understanding of folder
structure is required so let us see our
folders are organized for this
particular project we need to create two
different folders that are essential for
this particular project the first one is
resumes resumes is the folder where we
will have all the input files all the
resumes that we have got in this project
so in this project we have taken three
resumes and all those three resumes will
be present inside this folder resumes
then the next folder that we would need
is output folder which will have two
subfolders the first one is text
text txt will contain all the text
converted format of those resumes so
once the resume a pdf is read and then
convert it into a txt that is stored
inside this text folder and then once
the entire parsing is done all those
content is converted into a structured
tabular format which is a csv and then
it is stored inside this folder csv so
first we need resumes folder where we
will have all the pdfs that we want to
be parsed second we will have output
folder inside output folder we will have
two subfolders one is txt and then the
second one is csv
once you are done with creating these
folders the next important file that we
need for this particular project is pdf2
txt dot py so the file that we need is
pdf2 txt dot py and how do we get this
file
this is a file that is present inside
the pdf miner library so we need to get
this file from the pdf miner library so
let us go ahead and then open the pdf
miner
pdf miner.6 to be precise
pdf miner.6 github repository and then
let us go inside the tool section so
open pdf miners
github repository
and then get into tools section so from
this tool section you can see that you
have pdf2 text dot py
click this
and then you will get
raw file once you click the raw file
you have this option when you press ctrl
s or if you are using mac command s or
you can use your firefox to say okay
save page as which will tell you okay
how do i have to save the file so once
you have this file saved in your local
drive the folder where you have bought
this project now we are ready to go
further with the coding so there are
three essential things two folders main
folders output and resumes and inside
output we want txt and then csv two
folders and then we need to get this pdf
to text dot py from the pdf miner github
repository and then store it inside the
current working directory the current
folder where this project is set up once
this is done let us go ahead and open
our jupyter notebook
so
until now what we saw is how the folder
structure is organized and what is the
essential file that we need that we
source just from pdf miner github
repository once this is done let us go
ahead and open our jupyter notebook once
you open the jupyter notebook please
create a new notebook by just going into
file new notebook python3 once you do
this thing your new notebook will be
ready
in the new notebook as we have a better
coding practice in the every project
that we have done
once you create
the new notebook by going to file new
notebook python 3
we will have a new notebook and as a
better coding practice we will start
with importing the library that are
required and then we'll create functions
that are required and then finally we'll
invoke those functions and
we have got the entire project setup in
the jupyter notebook so this is the flow
that we are going to follow while
creating the jupyter notebook so the
first one is we are going to load all
the packages that are required for this
project so if you remember from the
previous videos that we need five
essential packages the first one is pc
for natural language processing pdf
miner for pdf two text
d re for
rejects ox
os operating system os for file
manipulation
and then finally pandas for csv tabular
format
so pandas for csv tabular format once
this is done let us execute this thing
next we are going to import
the file
pdf2.txt.py
so next we are going to import pdf2 text
dot py
next we are going to import pdf2 text
dot py that we just downloaded from the
github repository that we have kept it
in our current working directory the
project folder so what we are going to
do is we are going to simply say import
pdf to text and then we are going to
execute this this is successfully
executed which means we have got the
file in the right drive
folder location
so the next task is the first
function that we are going to create is
for converting
pdf to text and we'll call this
function
convert underscore pdf so this function
is going to take one argument so this
function is going to take one argument
which is the file name so the file name
is going to be given inside this
function and then we'll see what else
this function is going to do so the
first thing is once we get the file name
that is passed into this function we are
going to say okay
split the file name
and then
add dot txt so
imagine you have got a file name let us
say okay
abdul machid which is my name
and pdf this is how a typical resume
might look like so what we are trying to
do is we are trying to create the
output file name so because when we are
going to convert the pdf into text we
also want to save the text in the folder
that we just saw so what we want to do
is we want to
create an output file name using this
input file name so when we use
os.path.split text on the input file
name what we get is we get
two items just like this so we get two
items so what we are trying to do is we
are going to take the
first one because python is zero index
language we are going to take the first
one like this and then we are saying
okay plus text
which gives us the new output file name
for the text file and then we are
assigning this name to the output file
name so understand that we got the input
file name like this
a pdf file and we are trying to remove
that extension dot pdf and then we are
trying to append this new extraction
that is dot txt and then this new
extension dot txt is appended to this
file name and then this name
is getting assigned
to this output underscore file name
once this is done we also have to define
where do we want to save this file so as
we saw just now in the folder structure
that we are going to have an output
folder and inside that output folder we
are going to have
all the txt files so what we are going
to write here is we are saying okay
give me the path which is output slash
txt slash and then this output file name
that we just created so our output file
is going to be saved in this file path
where it is output slash txt slash and
then the file name output file name with
dot txt extension so this one we are
going to assign it in output underscore
file path
the next thing is
the pdf2 text that we just imported it
has a main function and then it takes a
couple of arguments so what we want to
do is we want to save this file in that
particular location so we are going to
say okay the arguments that i'm passing
is the file name which i just received
and then
the output file name which is passed on
with this argument hyphen hyphen out
file and then the output file path where
it has to be saved so this is the
function
that helps us converting pdf to text
and save it in the given location
which is what we create here so the
output location is created here output
file name is created here so the input
file which is the dot pdf file is given
through this f and then the output file
is saved once that is done we would like
to present a message to the user saying
that the file has been successfully
saved this is just for the reference
and finally we are going to return the
output file path
and then we are reading it as an input
file so what we are doing is in the same
function
we are outputting
the red file so that is why we have got
open the file name
and then dot read which is a function to
read any file in python so ideally we
could have done it in two lines to say
okay i am reading the file and then i'm
passing that red object the file object
as returning but in to save space and
also for simplicity which is one of the
core philosophies of python to have
simple code what we are trying to do is
we are trying to do it in same line so
the file path which we are reading after
opening so this is what we are going to
return
so in this function convert underscore
pdf there are five things that we are
doing the first thing is we are creating
the output file name second thing is we
are creating the output file path and
then the third thing is we are
converting pdf to text and saving it in
the given location which is the output
file path then we are printing a user
message to say that this is successfully
done and then finally we are returning
the red file opened and read file
which we just saved and then with this
this function is done let us execute
this function
and this is just for sample we don't
need i'll delete this cell
once this is done now we are going to
use spacey to load the language model so
let us load the language model in this
line which we just saw
load the language model
once we have the language model
we are going to
create an output
file structure so we saw that the
ultimate objective of this project is to
capture four important content four
important components from the resume and
then make it a structured document which
is name
phone
email
skills and then these are going to be
the four columns that we have in our
output tabular format and for that we
are creating a dictionary a python
dictionary using the curly braces so if
you remember your basics of python
a python dictionary is created using
curly braces a python list is created
using your square brackets so what we
are trying to do is we are trying to
create a result dictionary and then we
are also creating four placeholder
values
names phones emails skills and then we
are making it a list so that when we
extract these information we can put
that
particular component the respective
component for example let us assume that
we have extracted name from the first
resume second resume third resume so we
have three names and those three names
will go into the placeholder list that
we have created names the phone numbers
will go into phones the email ids will
go into emails and then the skills will
go into skills
so with this we are ready with the
placeholder the type of output that we
would like to have once this is done we
are getting into the core function which
is going to extract the content
from the resume so with the placeholder
output now we are moving forward to see
how to define the function that will do
the extraction the core four component
extraction for this particular project
now that we have got the output
placeholder in place which is a
dictionary and then couple of list to
put the content inside it extracted
content inside it
we are moving forward to do the actual
core
component extraction part of this
particular project and this function
will call it as parse underscore content
which is to pass the content that we
have and the argument is text so this
function receives text if you remember
what we returned from this function is
the convert pdf function is
we opened the file
and then we read it which is a file
object and then in this function we are
going to read a text so that is how we
are interlinking those two functions and
we will see it in the future so the
first thing that is required for us is
to define what skill set that we are
expecting to extract from this project
so extract from the resume so the first
thing that we have to define is what are
all the set of skills the skill set that
we would like to extract from the resume
so considering a data science setup what
we are trying to do is we are trying to
see okay i want python and if you
remember your rejects you might remember
that a pipe operator signifies or
condition so python or java or sql or
hadoop or tableau so these are the five
things that we are trying to extract as
skills from a particular resume we are
trying to see whether this particular
resume has any of these things or all of
these things
the next thing is
phone number so what we are trying to do
is we are trying to
create a rejects that rejects should be
able to capture phone number and this
phone number rejects has been extracted
from this stack overflow answer so i
would like to give credit to that answer
that has
created a rejects that can handle
multiple different types of phone number
so
we saw
we want this as skill set so we are
compiling this
expression and then saving it in skill
set and this is the rejects to capture
the phone number and then we are
compiling it and saving it in phone
number
and then
what we are trying to do is
we are trying to
take the text that we just got inside
this function and then we are trying to
do annotation so if you remember the
basics of spacey video the first thing
that we have to do is annotation
once that is done
what we are trying to do is we are
trying to extract two entities
from
the annotated the past or the natural
language processing text so the text on
which the natural language processing
has been done
and the text is nothing but the resume
content okay so
from the past content or from the
extracted text content now we are trying
to do two things the first thing is
extract name the second thing is email
so totally we want four components which
is name email phone number and skill set
and we just saw creating regular
expressions for skill set and phone
number and now we are trying to extract
name and email id and to start with name
what we are trying to do is
entity any named entity recognition has
one particular label which is called a
person that signifies the name of a
person
so what we are trying to do is we are
trying to do
if
the entity label is person
then give me that entity text and assign
it in name
so this in python is called a list
comprehension which means instead of
writing a for loop in multiple step you
can write it in a single step so what we
are doing is we are doing a list
comprehension and then we are saying
okay whenever the entity recognized
entity
whose label is person
then give me that entity text and then
we are saying okay
what if a resume has multiple names for
example first the name of the person
would be on the top of the resume
probably their dad's name and mom's name
is there so for that with that
assumption that the person's name is
always on top of the resume you're
saying give me the first name that you
detect so we are trying to take the
first name that is detected in the
resume and then assign it to name
next we are also printing the name for
us to have some reference whose resume
we have passed next is we are trying to
do
email id extraction so what we are
trying to do is we are trying to say
okay
for every word the tokenized word in the
document
if the word
is like email so spacey has such an
attribute
like underscore email if this word like
underscore email which is returning a
boolean value either true or false if it
is true
then
give me the word and i'm telling okay
give me the first word there could be
multiple email ids but i don't care
about the second and third email id at
least for this particular project so
what i'm saying is okay give me the
first email id and then store it in
email and then print the email id again
for our reference
now that we have built the regular
expression for skill set and phone
number it is time for us to use
the expression that we have compiled and
then extract so there is one thing that
we have to note is
we are trying to convert the text entire
text into a lower case before even
proceeding further with the regular
expression this is to solve the case
issue so it could be like for example
let us say this is python someone could
have written python as capital p ytohn
someone could have written sql as sql
capital or small letter java could be
with j capital so to solve this all
these issues we are normalizing all the
text or downgrading all the text to a
lower case
and then we are saying okay rejects
find all where you have phone number
pattern
and then the string on which you have to
find is
text which is what the argument that we
got and then after converting into lower
case and then we are assigning the
output to phone after converting it to a
string object so
simply we have the text we are
converting into a lower text the text is
the regiment x we are converting
everything into lowered case and then we
are trying to find
all everywhere in this resume with this
regular expression and then we are
converting that result into a string and
then assigning it to a phone object and
then the same thing that we are trying
to do here is
find all the skill set
takes lower and then assign it to a
skills underscore list because we will
have multiple skills so one resume could
have python and java both so that is why
we are calling it a skills underscore
list
also one thing that we have to notice in
one particular resume we could have
multiple instances of python and java
for example let us assume in the
technical skill section someone has
mentioned python but also while
describing the project they might have
used the word python so what we would
end up getting here is in the skills
underscore list we would end up getting
python two times and we don't want to
record python two times for that matter
because we want to see whether python is
present or not present
so what we are trying to do is we are
trying to say okay
convert it to a dictionary which means
of course it will have only unique
elements and then we are converting that
into a string and then assigning it to
unique underscore skills underscore list
so
in this entire section
we have defined the regular expression
for skill set and phone number
we have used spacey for annotation and
then we have used the annotated text to
extract a person and then assign it to
name to see whether there is anything
like email then assign it to email and
then we have used phone number and skill
set regular expression that we just
compiled to find everywhere where we
have got and then we have got the skills
and unique skills so right now after
this what we are trying to do is we are
trying to append these names
in the placeholder list that we just
created so these are the four empty
placeholder list that we created so we
are trying to append all these that we
just extracted in those list and then
finally we are trying to print
a message a message to the user to say
extraction has been completed
successfully so for a small summary this
is the function the core function where
we are extracting the four components
it takes one argument which is the text
of the resume and then initially we are
compiling the regular expression for
skill set and phone number next we are
annotating the text document using
natural language processing of spacey
and then we are extracting name and then
we are extracting email and then we are
extracting phone number and then we are
extracting skills and then making unique
skills out of it and then we are
appending all those values in the
placeholder list that we created in the
previous cell and then finally printing
a user message to say extraction has
been completed so let us execute this
thing and it has been successfully
executed
in the next line what we are trying to
do is we are trying to say okay
now i've got two main functions one to
convert all the pdf to text and also you
know meanwhile save the text file in the
particular folder second use the text
content and extract whatever i wanted
the four components name phone number
email id skills
and with this set now what i have to do
is
i have to make this project work on
multiple files rather than only one pdf
file so that's the entire objective of
doing an automated bulk resume parser
right so you don't really want to use a
code just to
pass only one resume because a human
being of course could be better in
passing one resume but assume that you
are a manager and then you have got 100
resumes or 200 resumes or 50 resumes and
this is the case where we want to have
an automated resume parser bulk resume
parser and that is exactly what we are
trying to do here so what we are trying
to do here is we are trying to list down
all the files inside the folder resume
so as we just saw we have three files
inside resume we have three resume files
and then we are saying okay list down
all the files and iterate through each
of the file calling it as file so
we will take individual resumes and we
are calling it file
and then we are trying to just validate
whether the file name ends with dot pdf
so in the same folder you could have
let's say
uh forgotten to convert a docx file into
pdf so what we are trying to do is we
are trying to add an extra layer of
validation to say okay i want only pdf
because right now this code is built
only to function with pdf and if you
have got a docx you have to manually
convert a docx
to a pdf or you could find a lot of
script online to convert docx to pdf so
we are saying okay if the file name ends
with dot pdf then first print the user
message that we are reading the file and
then read the file
where convert underscore pdf is the
function that the function that we just
created invoking that and then the path
where we have all the files is this one
so the first file in the first iteration
it will be the name of the first file
in the second iteration it will be the
name of the second file and in the third
iteration it will be the name of the
third file and as we saw in this convert
underscore pdf we are returning a file
object
we opened the file using the path and
also we read it
so
we are assigning that output inside this
object called txt
and then now we are passing this txt to
the function that we just built here so
this takes one text
object as argument so we are passing
that
as the parameter here saying okay parse
underscore content txt
once we run this okay first resume is
red alice and parker's resume is read
and then the output is saved
successfully alice and parker's right is
the name email id so these are all
hypothetical names that do not exist so
it's a disclaimer that this is these are
all hypothetical resumes and do not
reflect to any living human being so
this is the first resume pdf is read
text is successfully saved the exact
same message that we printed here
and then we have the name which we also
printed here
and then we print the email id
which is here and then we finally say
extraction has been successful
so this is first resume
then this is second resume reading john
dominic
saving it as text name
email id extraction completed and then
finally ashley miles
reading
saving it as text extracting name email
id which is what we printed we didn't
print phone number and skills and then
extraction complete successfully so now
that we know that we have got three
resumes all those three resumes have
been successfully read what we are going
to do is
we are going to use these placeholder
values which is now populated with
all those names so to give you some
perspective
names
will have all the names
phone
will have all the phone numbers
skills will have all the skills and then
of course emails will have all the
emails now that we have got all the
values of this placeholders populated
now we are going to say okay
assign these
into these so this is a dictionary with
which is a key value pair and this is
the key and then we are going to put
this against the respective key as
values so what we are doing here is we
are saying okay
the value of this key should be names
the value of key this key should be
phones and the value of this key email
key should be emails and then finally
skills
then to see how does it look let us
execute this
then say result underscore dict which is
the result dictionary so as you can see
it starts with the curly brace ends with
the curly brace this is the key and this
is all the values this is the key this
is all the values so this is how a
typical dictionary in python would look
like
and then finally we have to convert into
a tabular format which we will do using
pandas data frame
so in this video we saw how to start
with importing libraries
define two important functions one is
converting pdf to text the second one is
the code the main function the it's like
the engine of the entire project which
is parsing the content and extracting
required components and then finally
storing the required components into a
python dictionary which in the next
video will see how to convert into a
tabular format using pandas and also to
save that csv as an excel file csv file
in this video
we'll see
how to convert the dictionary that we
created into a tabular format using
pandas and we will also see
how to then finally save this entire
thing as a script to run
on a bulk you know set of files in a
particular folder
so to start with
this is where we left in the previous
video where we had created result
underscore dict which is a dictionary
python dictionary with all the essential
content that we just extracted from the
three resumes that we had got in the
resumes folder
so to move ahead with we are going to
use pandas which we just imported at the
start import pandas pd is what we used
pd is an alias so we are going to use
that alias pd
dot
data frame
so the beauty of pandas is that pandas
data frame is nothing but
a python dictionary internally so it is
easier for us to convert
result underscore dict
into a data frame just by invoking this
function called
data frame
from this
alias pdp dot data frame
where frame is
the f is capital
d and for capital
and pass result underscore dict assign
it to result underscore df df stands for
data frame or you can give any name that
you would like to and then i am printing
df which says okay this is my name
this is my phone number
this is my email and these are the
skills that i've got so alison has got
python tableau in java john dominic has
got hadoop python and java ashley miles
has got sql and tableau and then the
next step is for us to save this entire
thing
into a csv file as we saw in the
previous video the folder structure that
we've got
where output has two folders subfolders
one is text which stores
all the text files that are converted
from pdf and in the csv where we have
got the output csv so we are going to
say okay save the output csv there and
then we can go ahead and open the folder
and see that the output
csv is present here
so until now what we have seen is
take the dictionary convert into a
tabular format which is a pandas data
frame and then save that data frame into
a csv file
but this jupyter notebook is good for us
to prototype
but now
the objective is we have a folder full
of resumes and then you know you want to
give this to someone who cannot use
proper python coding and then they
should be able to convert all those pdfs
into structured content and for that
purpose we are going to convert this
jupyter notebook into a python script
and then use that python script to
convert all those pdfs into text so let
us go ahead and then open file and then
go to download as
and then do dot poi
this will give us the python script
but before we do that we have to remove
those instances that are not required
for example
we have a lot of places where we have
printed these things which is quite
unnecessary so we'll delete these cells
you can use x to delete a cell or
probably you can go here and then
run
delete cell
so i'll use x
delete delete delete delete cool and
then i'm going to delete this dictionary
so we are done with this as of now
and uh we can save and checkpoint it
just for our reference then what we can
do further is we can go download
python dot py so we'll save the file
and then make sure that you have got the
file
inside the folder the current project
folder so bring that file here
the current project folder where we have
got all the files
so now you should have
the folders that we defined with the
resumes with input files resumes with
all the pdf resumes that we want to be
parsed
then the output folder with two
subfolders csv and text
txt
and then also
the pdf2 txt.py should be inside this
folder
and this is
the notebook that we just created to
create this entire project and then
finally
the
python script of this jupiter notebook
with this we are good to go that we have
got resume underscore passing which is
script we'll use this script on command
level
as a cli tool to automate this entire
process of converting pdfs into a
structured format of valuable content
but before we do that
let us
go ahead
and then delete these things because
these were created when we ran this
particular code in the jupyter notebook
but to make sure that the project is
successful we'll delete this and also
we'll delete the output file we have got
an output file we'll delete this output
file also so right now
let us just validate we have got three
resumes alice and parker ashley mills
dominic john dominic
and in fact you can notice that this is
all three different formats this is a
double column
this is a single page resume so we have
got different resume formats and then
output does not have anything output is
empty with two sub folders empty
subfolders and then we are all set to
test our script on this resumes folder
to see the code that we just have
created using the jupyter notebook the
python script that we just downloaded
from the jupyter notebook if it could be
used for automation so open the terminal
or if you are using windows please open
your command prompt and then make sure
that you are inside
the project folder so
my project folder name is resume parsing
i can use ls to check
okay
or if you are using uh
windows check the command to see where
you have got your current folder so you
can see that this is my current folder
and then it shows that i've got this
file regime underscore parsing
in place
and i've also got the folders like
output resumes and the main pdf to txt
dot py file so with this what we can do
is we can say resume
underscore parsing
dot py but before we do that we have to
say python 3
space resume underscore parsing dot py
so the same name that we have given here
you have to say python 3 resume
parsing.py once you press enter
we'll see all the details that we have
done so for example
this is exactly what we saw
first reading alice in parkers the first
resume output is txt is saved
name email extraction completed second
resume john dominic
john dominic txt is saved
name email id successfully completed and
then the third resume actually miles csv
reading pdf saving txt name email id
successfully completed
now we can see
okay ls nothing has changed let us enter
into resumes folder
and then we will see okay ls we can see
that there are three files which is what
we used as input now let us come out you
see the space dot dot coming out and
then doing ls just to validate where we
are and then let us get into output
and then you can see ls
we have two folders cd txt
and then ls
we can see that we have got three text
files so initially before we started
with this
execution of the script we did not have
these txt files
now we have this txt file which means
the conversion of pdf to txt has been
successful now let us also validate
whether we have got the structured
information in the form of csv so let us
go out
cd space dot dot now we are again inside
output will get into csv
and then say okay we have got the csv
inside csv ls
we have got
parsed underscore resumes dot csv which
means the script that we executed
has completely done what we did with the
notebook which means the script is
perfect
that the automation is successful that
it picks all the resumes the folder
resume
and it converts everything into txt and
saves inside txt and then it also
finally creates one csv file which is
the parsed resumes file so now let us go
ahead
and go to output open csv now that we
find csv in this folder let us right
click it and open the csv with microsoft
excel for us to see okay
this is excel the csv has been opened
you can see that okay name is there
phone number is there email id is there
skill is there and how can you use the
output of this project let us assume
that you are a hr manager or the
recruiting manager and you want to use
the output of this project and you have
got let's say maybe 100 names like that
the way you can use it is
right now you have
a requirement for a sql developer sql
developer what can you do you can just
go there
apply this filter and say
okay i want
someone with
sql
then what do you get
let's say
you go to the header
let us format this header
little bit and then you go to the header
and then say filter
and i want someone with sql then you see
oh you have got ashley miles with sql
set and additionally ashley miles also
has tableau so maybe let us pick up
ashley email's email id and then mail
and ask if he would be interested in
joining our company for an interview
or let us assume that you have another
requirement where you want someone with
tableau and then in this case you will
go put a filter
and say
one tab blue
then you see okay alice and parker
wright and ashley miles has tableau as
skill set and then you know now let us
prioritize that these two resumes for
interview and then go ahead and then
call them for interview so this is the
main objective of this project so if you
have got a lot of resumes like 50
resumes it is nearly impossible for one
human being to literally go through all
the resumes but using an automated
script a bulk resume parser that we have
built using this project what we can do
is we can extract the essential skill
set that we want and as you know you can
change the skill set like you wanted in
the rejects expression that we built and
then filter it using excel to say okay
these are the resumes that i'm going to
focus instead of just going uh randomly
with all the 50 resumes
so in this section we learned how to
build an automated bulk resume parser
using natural language processing and
regular expression we also alongside
learnt basics of regular expression and
how to implement it in python and we
also saw
introduction to spacey
and natural language processing using
spacey and then once we successfully
built the script to completely convert a
resume which is in pdf and unstructured
format into a structured tabular format
we saved it in csv and we saw how we can
use that csv to prioritize resumes for
selecting the right resume for the job
requirement
thank you for watching this video and
we'll see the next section
in this section we'll learn how to build
an image type converter converting
images from one image type to another
image type like png to jpg jpg to png or
bmp to png
is one of the most wanted tools that
every one of us expect to have handy
to build such a tool we'll start
learning with basic image manipulation
in python then we'll understand what are
the python packages used for image
manipulation and then finally we'll
build a tool that helps us do image type
conversion
this section contains following topics
what are the different types of an image
what is an image type converter
introduction to image manipulation in
python and the python packages used for
that and then finally we'll build a
script project that will help us do
image type conversion in the next video
we'll learn what are the different types
of image file formats and its details
in this video we'll learn what are the
different type of image file formats and
its details
image file formats are standardized
means of organizing and storing digital
images
the image file format is usually
identified by the image file format
extension that comes with the file name
an image file format is required to
store data in an uncompressed or
compressed or vector format once
rasterized an image becomes a grid of
pixels
each of which has a number of bits to
designate its color equal to the color
depth of the device displaying it
in general an image file format defines
how data is stored the image data is
stored in that particular file format
an image compression can be of two types
one is a lossless compression the other
one is a lossy compression in a lossless
compression the image in file format is
changed the compression is usually
lossless which means there is no
information loss in a lossy compression
the algorithm preserve a representation
of the original uncompressed image that
may appear to be a perfect copy but it
is not so often lossy compression
able to achieve smaller file sizes than
lossless compression and it is highly
preferred when you are going to transfer
image
from one place to another place
where you need to compress the image
what are the various different types of
image file format
the most widely used and
in internet the file format that has
been highly preferred to be used for
image transfer is jpeg jpeg stands for
joint photographic
experts group which is a lossy
compression which means jpeg is a
compression algorithm that stores image
data in a compressed format
after jpeg one of the highly
preferred file format is png png stands
for portable network graphics file
format png was originally created as an
alternative for gif or gif however you
want to say it give stands for graphics
interchange format
in the next video we'll see what are the
different python packages that we'll be
using in this particular project
in this video we'll learn about the
different types of python packages that
we will be using in this particular
project
for image manipulation we are going to
use the package called
p
pil
l stands for python imaging library
python imaging library is one of the
most popular python package which is
free for image manipulation in python
however there was no recent support from
pil for any python version that is
greater than 3
which means pl supports only python
version that is lesser than 2.7 so for
this someone has forked a friendly fork
of pil repository and that is called
pillow pillow now supports any new
latest python version that is greater
than three pillow was created by alex
clark and its contributors so pillow is
the library for image manipulation that
we are going to use in this particular
project pillow follows the same syntax
as pil
you have to make sure in a computer
where you have installed pillow that you
do not have pil
pillow can be installed using pip which
will see later on the next package that
we are going to use in this project is
globe globe is simply for
unix style path manipulation so to
identify the files images in our current
folder we are going to use globe so we
are going to use globe to identify the
current image files that is in our
current directory and then we are going
to use pillow for converting into from
one format to another format in the next
video we will learn how to install the
required python packages and loading
them into our project
in this video we'll learn how to install
the required python packages and loading
them into our project
as we discussed earlier the package that
we are going to use is called pillow so
let us open our terminal if you are
going to use mac open your terminal or
if you are going to use windows open
your command prompt and make sure that
in your computer
if you have python 3
you are going to use pip 3 so if you are
going to have python 3 use pip3 or if
you are going to have python
less than 3.0 use pip so in my computer
i have got python 3.7 so i am going to
use pip 3 and install and below make
sure that your p in pillow is in capital
letter and then
press enter the installation procedure
will start now
so right now you can see that pillow has
been installed successfully for you to
verify pillow has been installed
successfully you can open python console
here using python 3
and then import
below
the reason that pillow is not found here
is because we also saw that pillow
follows the same syntax as pil but it is
just a simple fork so in this case if
you are going to use pillow you have to
just simply import p i l
make sure that you have only one version
of pillow installed in your machine so
that there is no clash among the
packages
this is the only package that was
required for us to install the other
package that we saw globe is already
available which also we can verify by
using
import
globe
it has been imported which means the
package is available already by default
in python 3.0
in the next video we'll start with the
coding part of creating our image type
converter script
in this video we'll learn how to code or
image type converter script
to begin with open your pycharm or any
other python id that you are going to
use for this particular project
once you open your id or pycharm in my
particular case
go to file and click new to create a new
python file once you click new you'll
get all these options and select python
file to create a new python file you
might have to name the file up front so
give a meaningful name like image
conversion new
dot py
for ease of process i've already created
the code and i'll take you through
section by section the first section we
are going to load the library that we
are going to use in this particular
project
as we discussed earlier even though the
package name that we are going to use is
called pillow
because it is a fork of pil library so
we are going to use pil so from pl we
want to import the class object image
and then we are going to import globe
which is to identify the files with the
particular extension so in this step we
are going to use print globe.globe
and we are going to use this small
regular expression pattern that tells us
that anything that starts with
anything and then followed by a dot and
then finally ends with a png which means
we are going to tell python that please
give me the list of files that have an
extension png
to understand this let us see the
current working directory of ours in the
current working directory of us we have
three png files as you can see the first
one is batman lego the second one is
pump of girls another third one is
tarmanjari.png so all these png files
will be displayed
once we run this code in the next
section we are going to iterate through
the png files each and every file and
then we are going to open the image file
and then assign it to a new python
variable called im
once we assign it to the new python
variable called i am we are going to use
this i am
to apply a method called convert where
we are converting into two into its rgb
file format rgb stands for red green
blue which forms the complete color that
we usually see so in this step we're
going to convert
the image that we read which is a png
image after getting assigned into a new
object we're going to convert it into
its rgb format
please note that
image conversion can also have rgba but
rgba is not something that we are going
to use here for that purpose because
jpeg is a file format that cannot retain
transparency a stands for alpha alpha
represents transparency so for a jpg
image it has only three properties which
is r g b but for a png image for example
if you're going to convert from a jpg to
png image you need to have rgb a which
will convert the image into a new file
format along with this attribute alpha
which stands for transparency which is
not required for our current use case so
we'll use rgb format and convert the
input image and then finally while
saving the image we are going to use the
same file name
which is what we read and then we are
just going to replace the extension from
png to jpg and then it also gives us the
flexibility of setting a quality value
depending upon how large the images so
if you want the image to be more
compressed low quality if you want to
upload it online then you can reduce the
quality which means the size of the
image will also be reduced because we
have given it in a for loop it is going
to happen for all the files that we have
got so let us go ahead and run the code
so to run the code we can go here in
pycharm and then just execute the code
as you can see the code has completely
executed and then it has displayed all
the png that we had
and then it also has finished with exit
code 0. as you might have noticed
initially when we had opened this finder
the explorer where we had all the files
we had only png file format but you can
see now that we have also created
new jpeg file format and to notice the
difference when you open batman ligo
file you can actually see that there is
no background in there which means it is
completely transparent which is one of
the attributes of a png image but when
you actually see the jpeg image which is
this one you actually see that the
entire background has been filled with
the black color that is what happens
when we had done this conversion where
the attribute alpha has been lost
so in this project we learned how to
import the python image library how to
find png in the current working
directory and then how to convert this
image from one file format to another
file format
with different quality level compression
level in the next video we'll learn how
to execute our python project that we
just created using the terminal
in this video we'll learn how to execute
our python project using terminal or
command prompt
what we did in the previous project is
we imported below package and then we
iterated through all the png files in
our current directory and then we
converted all those png files into a
jpeg but the problem with that in
sharing the code is that someone has to
have the knowledge of python to open the
text editor or to open pycharm and then
run the code to avoid that we can
convert this entire code
into a python executable file which is
something that we have already created
in the previous project so the dot pi
file that we had created in the previous
project is what we are going to use in
our terminal our bash our shell our
windows uh command prompt and then use
that py file to execute and then convert
everything within our shell itself so
this way we can convert the entire
project into a single click command line
utility so let us first get into our
current working directory where we have
got all the files and the code
in my case image type conversion is
where i've got image underscore
conversion is where i've got my codes
and then project file to check that we
can use the linux command
ls to see what are all the files in our
current directory so as you can see we
have three png files and we have the
python file that we had created in the
previous project so to execute this file
let us first copy this file name
right click
copy
and once the file name is copied
remember whether you have got python or
just python 3 which means if you have
got python less than 3.0 you have to use
this command python or if you have to if
you have python version greater than 3.0
you have to use python 3. so in my case
i've got python version 3.0 so i'm going
to use python 3 here as the first
command and then i'm going to put my
file name which is image underscore
conversion dot py this command is going
to execute image underscore conversion
dot pi which will iterate through these
png files and create new jpeg files so
let us see
so as we have executed in just a micro
second this entire code has got executed
and then we can see that the png files
have got listed
and then the code has completely
successfully executed now let us see
whether the new files are there
available in the current working
directory so to check that we can use
the same command ls and then c as you
can see
we have new files which has this
extension called jpg jpg and
jpg so let us go to the
folder where we have got all these files
as you can see
initially we had only png files and
after this execution
we have all these jpg files to just
verify this one second will delete all
these jpg files
and then we'll go back and then check
using ls
yes there is no jpg files in this
current directory and then we'll run the
same command again to execute the image
conversion python file i'm going to use
python 3 because my python version is
greater than 2.7
so once we executed this we can go to
the current working directory and then
see that we have got new jpg files and
as we see last time
this
batman ligo has got no background which
is one of the properties of png files we
saw about alpha and the the jpg version
of the same batman lego has got a black
color background which means
the jpg file has replaced
the transparent background with a black
color so this project we learned how to
create an image type converter using
python using the library pil which
stands for python image library and then
we converted that code into a shell
script where we can execute in one line
that the entire conversion will happen
for all the png files in our current
working directory thank you for
listening see you in the next section
in this section we'll learn how to build
an automated new summarizer the reason
we call it an automated new summarizer
is because the machine learning
algorithm is doing the summarization
technique for us with no manual effort
of going through the long text of news
news summarization is nothing but the
text summarization of news will start
seeing an introduction to text
summarizer and its techniques will
implement one such text summarization
procedure in python with that we would
have extracted the summarized text of
the news and thus we would have got our
automated news summarizer in place let
us go ahead and start seeing the course
section
in this video we will learn about text
summarization text summarization is the
process of extracting meaningful text
that is shorter in length from a huge
chunk of larger text using algorithms
powered by natural language processing
and machine learning text summarization
is actually one of the most exciting
fields in machine learning and natural
language processing which is nlp
automated text summarization allows
engineers and data scientists to create
softwares and tools that can quickly
find and extract keywords and phrases
from documents thus creating a
summarized text text summarizers are
implemented in a variety of web
applications and mobile applications to
deliver summarized content or news and
the example is there is an app in short
which is one of the most popular news
apps in india that delivers a summarized
text from a larger news
ex summarization usually are of two
types the technique is of two types the
first one is extraction and the second
one is abstraction the extraction
technique the automated system or
algorithm that we have built extracts
objects from the entire collection of
text without modifying the objects which
means it extracts key phrases from the
entire text that we have given and then
ranks those sentences based on its
importance and then finally gives a text
summarized format of text using only
those most important sentences so in
this case there is no modification of
objects that are present inside the
actual text that has been provided
the second technique is abstraction
under abstraction instead of just merely
copying the information from the given
text what it does is it actually
paraphrases the entire section so it
takes the entire text paraphrases the
section and then finally identify key
words and then key phrases and then uses
natural language processing to create a
new text which is more meaningful and
also covers the context and then finally
it gives us the
summarized text of the original text
that has been given so there are two
techniques the first one is extraction
which actually returns the entire
document without modifying the objects
but the minimalistic version of using
only important sentences the second one
is it breaks down the entire sentence
multiple objects and then it builds
meaningful sentences using natural
language processing by paraphrasing the
sections and then we get the summarized
text
in the next video we'll learn about what
kind of technique we are going to use in
this particular project what python
package we are going to use for that
purpose and then how to install that
python package to proceed further thank
you
in the previous video we learned a bit
about text summarization in this video
we'll see what kind of text
summarization are we going to use and
then the python library required for
that so
text summarization is of two types as we
saw in the previous video one is
extraction the second one is abstraction
so in this particular project we'll use
extraction method for text summarization
and the python package that we are going
to use is called gensim so the gensim
implementation of text summarization is
based on a popular algorithm called text
rank text rank algorithm is a graph
based ranking model for text processing
an important aspect of text rank is that
it does not require deep linguistic
knowledge which means text rank model is
highly portable to any other domain or
language which means if you have built a
model using english language you can use
the same algorithm for a different
language without any further major
changes
jensen is also known as topic modeling
in python gensim is a pythonic library
for topic modeling document indexing and
similarity retrieval for large text
corpora the target audience for jensen
is the one who uses natural language
processing and information retrieval or
information extraction
gensim is particularly one of the most
popular python libraries especially for
topic modeling
gensim has been open sourced by a
company called ray technologies rare
rare technologies
let us see how to install gensim on a
computer open your terminal or if you
are using windows open your command
prompt and then type pip3 as we have
seen before if you are using python 3
you need to type pip3 install if you
already have got gensim so u is for
upgrade jensen
once you type this and enter
gensim would start getting downloaded on
your machine
as gensim is related to topic modeling
and then much more there are many
pre-trained models that comes with
gensim and language models also so for
that purpose gensim is quite heavy and
it would take some time to get installed
so as we can see gensim has got
installed successfully so let us clear
the terminal and open our python console
to see if gensim has been successfully
installed so import gensim
yeah as you can see gensim has been
successfully installed without any error
so we can now exit gen sim so jensen is
the library that we are going to use for
text summarization automated text
summarization but for us to get the text
itself because we are going to do new
summarization we need to extract the
text from news which means the news is
published on internet and we need to
extract text from news and to extract
text from news we are going to use
something called a beautiful soup as we
have seen in the previous sections
beautiful soup is the library that we
are going to use for extracting text
from internet as we can see it could be
from html or xml so beautiful soup is
the library that we are going to use for
web scraping which is to extract text
from internet to install beautiful soup
we need to type pip install beautiful
soup 4 so let us once again open our
terminal our shell and clear the text
that we have got in there and then
install beautiful so pip 3 install
beautiful soup
because it is the latest version of
beautiful soup so we have to type
beautiful soup for so as you can see
here the terminal that i have already
got beautiful soup installed in the
previous section so my beautiful soup
requirement has been already satisfied
if you have not got beautiful soup
beautiful soup would get freshly
installed on your machine
let us open our python console and then
try to see if we have got beautiful soup
installed so let us say from bs4 import
beautiful so which is the object of our
interest so as you can see beautiful
soup the object from the package
beautiful su 4 has been successfully
imported so remember this always when we
install beautiful soup it should be
installed as beautiful soup for all and
small glitters but when you are
importing beautiful soup it is from this
package bs4 and then you import object
beautiful soup so let us exit beautiful
soup
so in this video we learned
little bit about the kind of text
summarization technique that we are
going to use in this project the package
name jen sim that we are going to use in
this project how to install jensen and
then a little bit about gensim and we
also saw that we need beautiful soup the
python package beautiful soup for whip
scraping which is to extract text
from
the web url the news that we are going
to be of our interest in the next video
we will learn how to extract the news
text from the internet using beautiful
soup
in this video we'll see how to use
beautiful soup the python package
beautiful soup to extract text from the
internet news source so to begin with
let us import the packages that we want
for text extraction the first one is
beautiful soup as we know before
beautiful soup is a web scraping library
that we are going to use to extract text
from a new source the second package
that we are going to use is called
request
the request package is used to extract a
web content beautiful soup is used to
parse the text content that we extracted
using request package so after we import
the packages from bs4 import beautiful
soup from request import gate so the
reason why we are importing a particular
object or a function from a package
instead of loading the entire package is
because memory management if we have got
a huge
package like jensen and if we import the
entire package then the
primary memory would be occupied with a
huge memory chunk of this particular
package so it is always better to import
only the packages only the functions
only the objects that are our interest
rather than importing the entire package
so likewise beautiful soup object is of
our interest and the function request
that we wanted from
the request package so once we do that
thing let us create a custom function
the purpose of this function is to
extract only the text component so
extract only the text component from
paragraph text so in a typical website a
web url you would see text spread across
different tags it could be in a span tag
it could be in a h1 tag h2 h3 tag or it
could be in a div it could be anywhere
so the tag that is of our interest is
paragraph tag which is a html tag which
is denoted by this symbol
p so what we are going to do is we are
going to create a custom function
the first step in the function is the
function is reading the url so the
function is trying to get it since http
request to get the url using request
package and then it stores certain page
once it stores it in page we are going
to use beautiful soup to parse the
content
lx sigma parser so we are using lxml
parser to pass the content that we just
extracted using the get function and
then we are storing it in soup so next
step is we are going to identify only
the paragraph text and then we are going
to save it in text the reason we are
using lambda function is to iterate this
for different tags the reason is because
in a particular page there could be
different paragraph text so we are using
soup dot find all to find all the
paragraph text and then we are using
lambda function to iterate the speed of
text to all those paragraph function
that we found out and then we are
finally using join to join all the text
and store it in text object
the next thing is it is always good to
present the title so what we are going
to do is apart from the text that we
extracted we are going to extract the
title also the reason we are using soup
dot title dot strip strings is because
the title might sometime come with
escape strings like slash n the denotes
end of line or slash tab that denotes a
tab space so to strip out those strings
we are using soup dot title dot strip
strings and then again we are using join
to join all the words that we have got
and then store it in title and then
finally we are returning this as title
comma text which will be read as a tuple
so finally we are sending it as a tuple
and then the custom function that we
wanted to create is done the function
name is get underscore only underscore
text and then the argument that we are
passing is the url that we want to
extract the text from so once this
function is done let us execute this
and then the next step is then use url
from which we are going to extract the
text this is the url from where we are
extracting the news the news is from a
very popular media publishing site
called walks the news title is
california is cracking down on the gig
economy and then this is what we are
going to use to extract and summarize
text from
once we take this url and then we put
this url within the function that we
just created so you can see the function
that we created is called get underscore
only underscore text and then we are
passing this url
as a character or string the string
argument is passed on to this url and
let us execute this url as you can see
it just finished executing and let us
print the text object to see if it has
successfully scraped extracted the text
so you can see that the text is
available now and let us just see how
large this text is
in other words how many number of words
we have got so once we execute this
thing the way we find it out is we take
the string and then we split the strings
using str.split as words and then we are
using length of the words to see how
many words we have got so you might
doubt why have i used text
1 instead of just text so as we created
the function before i mentioned that we
are returning it as a tuple a tuple is a
different type of python object from a
list so a tuple is an immutable object
so the reason we have returned it as a
tuple is because we wanted to return
title and text in the same expression so
that is why we have returned both
so if you see text
length
of text
it would show you 2 which means it is a
tuple with two objects in it so you can
also see it opens with the open bracket
and it ends with a
close bracket
as opposed to a list which would open
with the square bracket and close with
the square bracket and that is the
reason why we are excluding this because
text of 0 would be the title and text of
1 is the actual text that you want so
text
of 0
would be the title and the text of 1 is
what we actually wanted and that is why
we are using text of 1
to use string split and then split it by
words and then calculate the number of
words in it so in this video we learned
how to use beautiful soup
and request to extract the text from the
new source and we also saw what is the
length of the
text the extracted text which is 1625
in the next video we will learn how to
do text summarization using jensen
in this video we'll see
how to
do text summarization automated text
summarization of that extracted text
that we did in the previous video so as
a first step we need to import all the
required python packages the python
package that we are going to use here is
gensim as we know before
and within gensim we are interested of
two functions one is summarize the
second one is keywords so from gensim we
are going to import summarize and
keywords so
say do
from gensim.summarization.summarizer
import summarize
and then from gensim.summarization
import keywords once you have typed this
in execute your jupyter notebook cell so
once this is executed your python
package has been successfully imported
so the next step is for us to
do text summarization tick summarization
as it might look very complicated gensim
is offering us this in a single function
so how we can do this is the first one
is the function called summarize and
then we have to pass the text to this so
the text that we have
extracted in the previous step as we saw
is a tuple so what we have to do is we
have to do text dot one
and then
the summarize function as a first
argument it takes text the actual text
content as a second argument it actually
takes ratio
and then the third argument is word
count the thing with this is it can be
either done with ratio or with word code
not with both so if you supply both
which means ratio let us say ratio is
equal to 0.01 so the ratio is nothing
but the ratio of text summarized text
that you want as opposed to the original
text so in text summarization we use
summarize as a function we can either
use ratio or
word count as argument to extract to
limit the amount of text that we wanted
so let us start with
the first method which will use using
word count
so
using summarize function we are passing
the text which is of text 1 and then we
are saying the word count that i want is
100 which means i do not want more than
100 so in the previous video we saw that
we have totally 1625 words and then we
are going to extract only 100 words out
of it which is meaningful a summarized
text so to make it a little bit
the cosmetic changes to the output we
are going to say okay this is the title
and then we are using text of 0 to print
the title and then we are saying this is
summary and then the summarize text once
we execute this thing
we see that we have got the title of
walks and then we are getting the
summarized text which says okay the
state assembly has passed the bill which
makes it harder for companies to label
worker as an independent contractor
instead of employees which is what
usually happens in gig economy
so as a first step we have extracted our
text and the number of
words that we have got is
let us say
is 98 so we limited our word count to
100 and then we have got 98 words so
this is the first method where we have
extracted the text
using word count as an argument to put a
threshold in the second method what we
are going to do is we are going to say i
do not want to put the threshold of word
count what i want is i am giving a ratio
the ratio can be anything between 0 and
1 and then within this it will use as an
approximation as a ratio of the original
text which is 1625
and then given this ratio it will give
us how much text that we are going to be
given so what we are going to do is we
are going to use the same function
text of 1 because we just wanted the
text and then we are going to say ratio
of 0.1 and then see how much are we
getting so you can see that you have got
the title and then you have got the text
if you want to reduce this text further
we can say instead of point zero one we
can say point zero
lets say seven
point zero seven which further reduces
the text if you are interested in
reading more text instead of point zero
one we can say point
two which is giving us more text
point one
is giving us less text
so
as you can see that we have extracted
the summary using a different method
other than specifying the word code but
still it is good for us to see how much
it has reduced so what we will do is
we'll copy this function which is where
we have got the output text
and then
we'll say we are going to put it as
summarized
text is equal to
this is what we'll execute this once we
execute this we have got the summarized
text now we are going to use the
summarize text
and then put it inside
our text
length function to see how many words we
have got we have got 217 words in the
previous method we got 98 words because
we had set a threshold using the word
count in this method we have set a
threshold using the ratio and then we
have got 217 words
so this is how we have extracted
summarized text but sometimes not just
summarize text is enough but you also
want to see the keywords that are more
important that the algorithm has found
out so what we are going to do in this
tip is we are going to extract the
keywords that is of more importance and
we are going to use the same method so
we are going to say keywords which is
the function name
for the first argument is the text that
we are passing the original text the
second argument is we are setting a
threshold using the ratio and then the
third argument says whether you want to
do lemmatization or not so to understand
what is limitization so let us first
execute this function without limitation
function so once you execute this thing
you might see okay the critical keywords
are drivers code codes
workers worker states state contractors
contractor
so even though it gives us keywords
sometimes you might see the repetition
one is court and quotes
state and states contractors and
contract
this is because we have not done
limitization limitization is a process
of taking a word and then converting it
to a root word for example workers would
be converted into worker codes would be
converted into code contractors would be
converted into contractor which means we
would not see duplication because of
that just one extra word so let us go
ahead and then do
lemmatization limit is
true
it's a boolean flag once we execute this
thing now we have got the new set of
keywords which is just codes uber
contractor business
worker and there is no plural form and
singular form because we have done
limitization
so we can do this for the other method
also so in this video we have learned
how to successfully do
automated text summarization using the
gensim function summarize and also we
learned to do it using two different
method one is using ratio the second one
is using word count apart from this we
also learned how to do ticks keyword
extraction so one is text summarization
the next one is keyword extraction to
find out more relevant or important
keywords for example if you are going to
run a google adwords campaign for this
particular text then you need to
understand what are the keywords
critical keywords that are presented in
this particular word text and then we'll
run the campaign we'll do the bidding
accordingly so in the next video we'll
learn how to make this a complete
project and then we'll see a summary
in this video we'll see how you can take
this further forward so as you can see
what we have done is we have used a
jupyter notebook to create this
particular project so jupyter notebook
is good if we want to incorporate text
which is narrative as markdown and also
the code and also the output but jupyter
notebook is not applicable for every
purpose so for example let us take that
you want to do this project as an
automation so what you want to do is you
want to take a particular url and then
you want to schedule this in your
computer to get the summarized text from
a new source every day let's say morning
so in that case what you can actually do
is you can go to your jupyter notebook
file
and then you can download this jupyter
notebook as a dot pi file so instead of
having it as a jupyter notebook you can
download this as a dot pi file which
means you are going to get a python code
dot py file which you can use your
windows task scheduler or mac automator
to schedule it every day at a certain
point of time so this is one thing that
you can do this in this project the
second thing what you can do is instead
of a jupyter notebook you can
use this jupyter notebook to create a
more generalized version of this project
and then you can convert it as a command
line project so where you can just
invoke this project with an argument of
url and then it would give you a
summarized text so in this project in
this cell if you see we have hard coded
the url
but instead of hard coding the url what
you can actually do is you can use this
as an argument that could be passed at
command level and then what you can do
is you can use your terminal to invoke
this python project passing the desired
url in the terminal as an argument and
then you can extract the text as an
output so there are two things that you
can do further with this project one is
extracting the python code and then
scheduling it so that you get the news
into your inbox every day or instead of
that you can have it as a python project
the same dot pi file but in a more
generalized format instead of hard
coding the url and then you can get the
extracted summarized text whenever you
supply a url to this particular project
but if you do not wish to do any of
these things you can just keep it as
this jupyter notebook and then what you
can do is whenever you want to change
the url you can give a different url
here and then the run the text and the
text would this algorithm this notebook
would give you the desired output where
you can use to read the news of a
summarized format like just like
headlines or how the in shorts app which
we saw that most popular news
application in india would be doing to
send a card of text which is a very
summarized version of the actual news
so in this video we learn how to take
this project further so far in this
section we learned how to build an
automated new summarizer we started with
understanding what is a new summarizer
and what kind of techniques are
available and then we learned about the
python packages required for it and then
finally we did
new summarizer using gensim and the text
extracted using beautiful soup i hope
you enjoyed the project thank you very
much